MORNING IN RESPONSE TO COVER
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THESE ORDERS THE
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS.
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL.
WITH MEMBERS ABLE TO PARTICIPATE
REMOTELY WE DON'T HAVE ANYONE.
WE DO OKAY WE DON'T HAVE ANY
MEMBERS OF PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY TODAY THE MEMBERS OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE ARE HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM THOSE PROVIDING
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY ARE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. FOR OUR REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK ASSET EVERY
TIME YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED
THAT YOU USE THE RAISE YOUR HAND
FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM EACH TIME
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A
POP UP WINDOW WILL APPEAR.
ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO UN
MUTE. PLEASE SELECT ON MUTE
BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING OUR IT
PERSONNEL BUT YOU BACK ON MUTE
WHEN YOU ARE DONE ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK. PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
YOU ARE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO THE HEARING
ROOM TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. I
WILL BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE. IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS TODAY'S. A
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS THREE FIVE THREE ONE. TWO
EIGHT THREE. FOUR DEAL DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE AND OR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED
TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR. TO DIAL
ONE THEN ZERO PRESS THIS ONLY
ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR
AN OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT
ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER HE WILL WAIT IN THE QUEUE
FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR
LINE NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU
WILL BE A MUTED AND YOU ARE NOW
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US
TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MEET
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE TEST THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY. AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEDIAN SERVICE
OR HAVE YOUR CONNECTIONS MUSIC.
BEFORE WE BEGIN LET'S ESTABLISH
A QUORUM. WILL DOCTOR BACK BILL
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
DORADO HERE SENATOR GROWTH
SENATOR CORTEZ SENIOR SENATOR
NEWMAN HERE. QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED THE SUB COMMITTEE OF
FIVE HEARING WILL COVER THE
OFFICE OF THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
AND REMAINING ISSUES RELATED TO
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
INCLUDING HEALTH CARE
INITIATIVES AND FACILITIES AND
CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS NO OKAY
THAT ONE IS NOT WILL NOT BE IT'S
JUST THE HEALTHCARE FACILITIES
NOT FACILITIES AND CAPITAL
OUTLAY PROJECTS. WE WILL FIRST
HEAR FROM THE ADMINISTRATION ON
THEIR PROPOSALS AND THEN WE WILL
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ALL ISSUES
WILL BE HELD OPEN AND THERE WILL
BE NO VOTES TAKEN TODAY WE WILL
BEGIN WITH THE ITEMS PROPOSED
FOR DISCUSSION AND MOVING ON
GOOD TO BE HERE GOOD MORNING TO
EVERYBODY- THE FIRST ISSUE IS
NUMBER ONE IS REFORMING THE
STAFF COMPLIANCE PROCESS. FIRST
WE WILL HEAR FROM- CDC ARE. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS AMY
MILLER AND I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
THE DIVISION OF CORRECTIONAL
POLICY RESEARCH AN INTERNAL
OVERSIGHT. FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION. CDCR IS
REQUESTING FUNDING AND POSITIONS
TO RESTRUCTURE THE DEPARTMENT
STAFF MISCONDUCT ALLEGATIONS
SCREENING REFERRAL INVESTIGATIVE
AND DISCIPLINARY PROCESSES.
THESE RESOURCES WILL BE USED TO
SUPPORT A STATEWIDE CENTRALIZED
SCREENING PROCESS FOR
ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF MISCONDUCT.
ADDITIONAL INVESTIGATION STAFF
TO ADDRESS THE INCREASED NUMBER
OF ALLEGATIONS THAT WILL BE
ROUTED TO THE OFFICE OF INTERNAL
AFFAIRS FOR INVESTIGATION. THE
LEGAL WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH
INCREASED NUMBERS OF
INVESTIGATIONS AND RESULTING
DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS. THE
SUPPORT STAFF NEEDED AT
INSTITUTIONS WITH THE GREATEST
WORKLOADS TO COORDINATE
ACTIVITIES RELATED TO STAFF
MISCONDUCT INVESTIGATIONS
INCLUDING THE SCHEDULING OF
INTERVIEWS AND COLLECTION OF
EVIDENCE. THE TECHNOLOGY
ENHANCEMENTS AND SUPPORT NEEDED
TO TRACK AND MONITOR ALLEGATIONS
STATEWIDE AND IT MINISTRY TO
STAFF NECESSARY DUE TO THE
SIGNIFICANT INCREASED NUMBERS OF
INTERNAL AFFAIRS AND LEGAL
AFFAIRS STAFF. ALONG WITH ME
TODAY ARE KRISTEN'S WYLER FROM
THE OFFICE OF LEGAL AFFAIRS AND
KIMBERLY CYCLE FROM THE DIVISION
OF ADULT INSTITUTIONS WE'RE
HAPPY HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE ON THIS
PROPOSAL AND WE CAN ALSO GIVE A
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF. THE CHANGES
IN THIS PROPOSAL IF YOU SO WISH
THANK YOU FOR- IF IT COULD BE
DONE VERY BRIEFLY I THINK AN
OVERVIEW WHO SHOULD BE A GOOD
THING TO START FROM THANK YOU.
COURSE MADAM CHAIR CELLS THE
FUNDING PROVIDED IN THIS REQUEST
WILL ENABLE THE DEPARTMENT TO
COMPLETELY RESTRUCTURE THE
PROCESS FOR REVIEWING
ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF MISCONDUCT
INVOLVING AN INCARCERATED PERSON
OR FRAWLEY. AB A FULLY AGREE
EVENTS WAS REVIEWED AT THE
INSTITUTION HER ROLE OFFICE OR
OTHER LOCATION WHERE THE
COMPLAINT ORIGINATED. IF IT WAS
DETERMINED TO INVOLVE A
COMPLAINT AGAINST STAFF. IT WAS
SENT TO THE LOCAL HIRING
AUTHORITY GENERALLY THE HIGHEST
RANKING PERSON WITHIN THAT STAFF
MEMBERS PROGRAMMER DIVISION. NOW
IN OUR NEW PROCESS THE REVIEW OF
ALLEGATIONS MADE BY INCARCERATED
PEOPLE OF CRAWLEY'S FROM THE
INSTITUTIONS AND THE PRO OFFICES
WILL BE TRANSFERRED FROM WHERE
THEY ORIGINATED. TO A
CENTRALIZED SCREENING TEAM
WITHIN THE OFFICE OF INTERNAL
AFFAIRS AT CDC OUR HEADQUARTERS.
THE CENTRALIZED SCREENING TEAM
REPLACES THE SCREENING OF
GRIEVANCES BY INSTITUTIONAL
AUTHORITIES AND CENTRALIZES THAT
SCREENING IN ONE OFFICE FOR
ACCURACY AND CONSISTENCY. AS
WELL AS REMOVED ANY ACTUAL OR
PERCEIVED LOCAL BIAS BY
ELIMINATING THE ABILITY
INSTITUTIONAL AUTHORITIES TO
REMOVE GREATEST SAYS FROM THE
REVIEW PROCESS. ALL INSTITUTIONS
AND PAROLE OFFICERS WILL ROUTE
GRIEVANCES AND COMPLAINTS TO THE
CENTRALIZED SCREENING TEAM
WITHIN THREE BUSINESS DAYS OF
RECEIVING THE GRIEVANCE OR
COMPLAINT. AND THE CENTRALIZED
SCREENING TEAM WILL BE TASKED
WITH REVIEWING COMPLAINTS AND
DETERMINING FIRST WHETHER
CONTAINS ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF
MISCONDUCT AND THEN SECOND IF IT
DOES CONTAIN AN ALLEGATION OF
MISCONDUCT WHETHER IT WILL BE
ROUTED TO THE HIRING AUTHORITY
FOR A LOCAL INQUIRY. WHETHER IT
WILL BE ROUTED TO THE OFFICE OF
INTERNAL AFFAIRS FOR A CRIMINAL. OR ADMINISTRATIVE
INVESTIGATION. WE'VE ALSO A
ALLERGY TO INDEX WHICH WILL BE
USED BY CENTRALIZED SCREENING
TEAMS TO DETERMINE WHEN A
COMPLAINT WILL BE ROUTED TO THE
OFFICE OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS FOR
INVESTIGATION. WELL EACH
COMPLAINT WILL BE INVESTIGATED A
COMPLAINT WILL BE REFERRED TO BY
A FRIEND DESTINATION WHAT
INVOLVES ALLEGATIONS OF USE OF
FORCE STAFF SEXUAL MISCONDUCT.
DISHONESTY DISCRIMINATION AND
HARASSMENT RETALIATION AND CODE
OF SILENCE. IF THE ALLEGATION
DOES NOT INVOLVE THOSE SPECIFIED
ALLEGATIONS ON THE ALLEGATION
DECISION INDEX IT WILL BE
REFERRED TO THE LOCAL HIRING
AUTHORITY FOR AN ALLEGATION
INQUIRY. HOWEVER EVEN THOSE
ALLEGATIONS GOING TO THE LOCAL
HIRING AUTHORITY WILL ONCE
THEY'RE COMPLETED BE ROUTED BACK
TO THE OFFICE OF INTERNAL
AFFAIRS WHERE THEY WILL BE
REVIEWED BY AN OFFICE OF
INTERNAL AFFAIRS MANAGER. TO
ENSURE THAT THEIR COMPLETE
UNBIASED AND THOROUGH BEFORE
BEING RETURNED TO THE
INSTITUTION SO THAT THE HIRING
AUTHORITY CAN MAKE A DECISION ON
THE ALLEGATIONS. THESE EFFORTS
COUPLED WITH OTHER INVESTMENTS
CHANGES REPRESENT A SIGNIFICANT
STEP IN OUR EFFORTS TO ENSURE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
IN OUR STOCK. COMPLAINT PROCESS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MILLER- WE WILL THE- UP ALLY G.
OFFICE PLEASE. GOOD MORNING.
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I AM EMBRACING. THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO BE HEARD ON
OUR PROPOSALS THIS MORNING OUR
PROPOSAL TODAY IS TO MONITOR THE
STAFF COMPLAINT PROCESS THAT WAS
JUST DESCRIBED TO YOU. WE ARE
ASKING FOR TWENTY FOUR POSITIONS
TO MONITOR THIS NEW PROCESS
WHICH IS BASED ON THE NEW
REGULATIONS ON AMENDING THE
CURRENT PROCESS THE DEPARTMENT
HAS IN PLACE. IN TWENTY NINETEEN
FOLLOWING REPORT RELEASED BY THE
O. I. G. BERMAN BEGAN DEVELOPING
A PROCESS TO ADDRESS
INCARCERATED PERSONS COMPLAINS
OF STAFF MISCONDUCT. ALSO AT
THAT TIME THE O. I. G. GAIN THE
ADDED RESPONSIBILITY TO PROVIDE
CONTEMPORANEOUSLY OVERSIGHT OF
THAT PROCESS. THE DEPARTMENT
DEVELOPED A PROCESS RESULTING IN
THE CREATION OF THEIR ALLEGATION
INCREASE THE MANAGEMENT SECTION
ALSO KNOWN AS BEING. A UNIT THAT
WAS DEDICATED TO CONDUCTING
ENQUIRIES INTO ALLEGATIONS OF
STAFF MISCONDUCT. IN RESPONSE
THE L. I. G. CREATED A TEAM OF
FIVE STAFF MEMBERS RESPONSIBLE
FOR MONITORING THE INCREASED
CONDUCTED BY GAINS. SINCE SPRING
OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO NOW OUR
TEAM OF FIVE CONTINUES TO
PERFORM THIS CONTEMPORANEA
OVERSIGHT OF THE DEPARTMENTS
PROCESS FOR REVIEWING AND
INVESTIGATING INCARCERATED
PERSONS ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF
MISCONDUCT. THE TEAM ALSO TRACKS
THE ALLEGATIONS THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT HEADQUARTERS APPEAL
PROCESS. CURRENTLY WE USE A
COMBINATION OF IN PERSON AND
REMOTE MONITORING TO OVERSEE
THESE GAMES AND CURRY. OUR TEAM
ALSO COLLECTS AND ANALYZES
VARIOUS STAFF COMPLAINT RELATED
DATA POINTS INCLUDING AIMS
WORKLOAD STATISTICS AND STAFF
COMPLAINTS WERE PERTAINS BY THE
PRESENT. GOING FORWARD OUR
PROPOSAL WILL MONITOR THE
DEPARTMENT'S IMPLEMENTATION OF
THEIR NEW STAFF COMPLAINT
INVESTIGATION PROCESS WE ARE
ASKING FOR STAFF TO MONITOR 30%
OF THE DECISIONS THAT WILL BE
MADE BY THE DEPARTMENT
CENTRALIZED SCREENING CHANGE.
THE PURPOSE IS TO ENSURE THE
TEAM IS CONSISTENTLY MAKING
DECISIONS AND THE DECISIONS MADE
ARE IN REGARDS TO THE PROPER
HANDLING OF THE GRIEVANCES
RECEIVED FROM INCARCERATED
PERCENT. WE ARE ALSOASKING FOR
STAFF TO MONITOR 10% OF THE
INVESTIGATIONS. DR ED BY THE
DEPARTMENT'S NEWLY CREATED AN
ALLEGATION INVESTIGATION UNIT
ALSO KNOWN AS A ARE YOU.
INFORMATION CONTAINED IN THE
DEPARTMENT'S NEW REGULATIONS
INDICATES THAT THESE CASES WILL
BE THE MOST SERIOUS AND COMPLEX
ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF MISCONDUCT
ARE MONITORING OF THESE CASES
WILL PROVIDE TRANSPARENCY INTO
WHETHER THE DEPARTMENT IS
CONDUCTING THOROUGH COMPLETE AND
UNBIASED INVESTIGATIONS. WE ARE
ALSO WORKING ON A MECHANISM TO
PROVIDE TIMELY FEEDBACK TO THE
DEPARTMENT AND TO ISSUE PUBLIC
PORTS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
I'M AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISSING- WOULD LIKE TO ASK
FINANCE FOR YOUR COMMENTS. GOOD
MORNING A BRAND COULD BE WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- THE
ADMINISTRATION IS IN THE PROCESS
OF EXPLORING VARIOUS OPTIONS AND
MAY BRING PORTER PROPOSAL FOR
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES IN THE
SPRING. THIS INCLUDES
CONSIDERING RESOURCES ANSWER
LOOKS TO OVERSIGHT OF LOCAL
INCREASED THE MINISTRATIONS
PROPOSAL PROVIDES RESOURCES FOR
THE ORGY TO MONITOR
APPROXIMATELY 10% OF THE
INVESTIGATIONS CONDUCTED BY THE
ALLEGATION INVESTIGATION UNIT.
ROUGHLY A HUNDRED FORTY OUT OF
EIGHT HUNDRED OUT OF EIGHTY FOUR
HUNDRED INVESTIGATIONS OF THIS
PROPOSED. WAS AIMED AT PROVIDE.
YOU WITH RESOURCE TO OVERSEE THE
MOST SERVICE COMPLEX CASES BASED
ON THE ALLEGATION ASSISTANT
POSITION INDEX THOSE
INCORPORATED INTO CCAR'S REGULAR
. AS THE- GENERAL KIND- THE
TEMPER I MEAN FOR SAMPLE SIZE
TOTAL BECAUSE FOR RANGE OF.
ALLEGATIONS THE ALLEGATION
INVESTIGATION UNIT WILL BE
INVESTIGATING WHILE PROVIDING
THOUGH I G. WITH THE ABILITY TO
OVERSEE THE MOST SERIOUS CASES.
OF FIVE OMAN THROUGH MONITORING
ALSO RECOGNIZES THE MANY
IMPROVEMENTS TO THIS YEAR HAS
MADE IN THE STAFF MISCONDUCT
PROCESS. BUT WE WILL LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON THIS PROPOSAL
OVER THE NEXT FEW MONTHS AS WE
WORK TO. THANK YOU MUCH I WOULD
ON NOW TO HEAR FROM THE L. A.
OLE MISS O'NEILL. THE MORNING
MORNING. CAITLYN ARE NOW AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE- WE
FIND THAT THE PROPOSED.
RESOURCES FOR CDCR TO IMPLEMENT
A STAFF COMPLAINT PROCESS
REASONABLE HOWEVER WE FIND THAT
THE PROPOSED LEVEL OF ARRANGING
MONITORING OF THAT PROCESS MAY
NOT. MEET LEGISLATIVE
EXPECTATIONS FOR OVERSIGHT. SO
WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE DETERMINE ITS
SPECIFIC EXPECTATIONS FOR
OVERSIGHT AND SIGNAGE- AG
RESOURCES ACCORDINGLY. AND TO
HELP THE LEGISLATURE THINK
THROUGH. ITS EXPECTATIONS FOR
OVERSIGHT. AND HOW THAT MAY
CARRY OVER INTO- I G. REISS. WE
PROVIDE THREE QUESTIONS FOR
LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION WHICH
ARE FIRST SHOULD- I. G. MONITOR
ALL TYPES OF CLAIMS RECEIVED BY
THE CENTRALIZED SCREENING. UNDER
THE PROPOSAL OR G. WOULD ONLY BE
MONITORING. GULAR GRIEVANCES
THAT ARE RECEIVED 30% OF REGULAR
GRIEVANCES I RECEIVE I TO
CENTRALLY SCREENING TEAM. I
WOULD NOT UNDER THE PROPOSAL
MONITOR HEALTH CARE GRIEVANCES
REQUESTS FOR REASONABLE
ACCOMMODATION OR THIRD PARTY
FILED CLAIMS SATISFIED- MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC. SECOND SHOULD
ALREADY MONITOR A LARGER PORTION
OF INVESTIGATIONS AS YOU HEARD
OR G. IS PROPOSING TO MONITOR
10% OF INVESTIGATIONS UNDER THE
NEW PROCESS. HOWEVER WE NOTE
THAT EIGHTY. EIGHT EXISTING-
SEPARATE YET SOMEWHAT ANALOGOUS
PROCESS THROUGH WHICH CDC ARE-
HANDLES ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF
MISCONDUCT REFERRED BY WARDENS
ANOTHER HIRING AUTHORITIES-
UNDER THAT PROCESS FOR THAT
PROCESS- AG MONITORS ABOUT 15%
OF INVESTIGATIONS. AND THE
LETTER THE LETTER MAY DECIDE
THAT IT IT WANTS A DIFFERENT YOU
KNOW A LARGER PERCENTAGE SIMILAR
PERCENTAGE- TO THAT PROCESS- AND
THEN START IT SHOULD- I. G.
MONITOR THE QUALITY OF THE
ROUGHLY THIRTY SEVEN THOUSAND.
LOCAL INQUIRY INCREASE THAT ARE
CONDUCTED UNDER THIS PROCESS SO
AS WAS MENTIONED- ALLEGATIONS
AND DON'T NEED TO BE. DON'T
FOLLOW THE ALLEGATIONS- INQUIRY.
THE ALLEGATION INDEX- FOR
REFERRAL TO LOOK FOR IN A WAY A
INVESTIGATION WILL BE REFERRED
BACK TO THE PRISON OR PAROLE
REGION FOR A LOCAL INQUIRY- AND
UNDER THE PROPOSAL- AG WOULD
NOT. MONITOR THOSE INCREASED OR
THE REPORTS THAT ARE PRODUCED.
THROUGH THEM. SO IT'S PAST THAT
SO THE LEGISLATURE COULD
CONSIDER WHETHER IT WOULD WANT
TO PROVIDE OR JEWISH RESOURCES
TO EITHER MONITOR THOSE
ENQUIRIES AND SALAS OR- MONITOR
THE REPORTS THAT COME OUT OF
TIME. FOR INDEPENDENCE AND
COMPLETENESS. AND I'M AVAILABLE
FOR QUESTIONS. GREAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- POLICE WILL MOVE ON
TO- ON YOUR OWN QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. YES SENATE QUARTERS IN
. THANK YOU VENTURE A GUESS I'D
LIKE TO HEAR A LITTLE BIT MORE
FROM- CDC ARE REGARDING THE L.
A. THOSE COMMENTS- RIGHT I HAD
SIMILAR NOTES. REGARDING. THE
POTENTIAL YOU KNOW LACK OF
ACCOUNTABILITY WITH STE WHAT
APPEARS TO BE SO MUCH OF THE
GRIEVANCE PROCESS- SELF
REGULATED. LISA TIME
UNDERSTANDING IT- IN IN THE L.
A- TALKED ABOUT THE LEGISLATURE
STEPPING IN AND YOU KNOW GIVEN
SOME MORE GUIDANCE BUT I GUESS
I'M JUST WONDERING CAN. CDCR
TAKE SOME OF THAT. ADVICE INTO
ACCOUNT- IF THAT'S THE SENTIMENT
THAT YOU'RE HEARING FROM- FROM
FOLKS INCLUDING US- IT DOESN'T
REALLY REQUIRE LEGISLATION TO
COME IN AND SET THE SYSTEM UP SO
THAT PERHAPS THE O. I. G. TAKES
A GREATER PERCENTAGE OF THE
CASES OR- A COMES IN AND DOES
SOME ADDITIONAL MONITORING JUST
TO. TO MAKE SURE THAT- BUT
EVERYTHING'S. FALLING OF
ACCORDING TO PLAN SO THAT THAT'S
MY QUESTION AND IT IS JUST HOW
MUCH ARE YOU WILLING TO DO MORE
HERE. THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION SENATOR- I'D LIKE TO
START BY SAYING THAT AS AN
AGENCY WE TAKE EVERY ALLEGATION
OF STAFF MISCONDUCT VERY
SERIOUSLY AND WE ARE COMMITTED.
TO ENSURING THAT ALL ALLEGATIONS
ARE DRESSED PROPERLY FAIRLY AND
THOROUGHLY. WE DO HAVE KNOWLEDGE
THAT THE OFFICE OF THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL'S ROLE IN OUR PROCESS-
AND WE WELCOME THEIR
CONTRIBUTIONS AND REVIEWS. WE
MAKE EVERY EFFORT TO COORDINATE
WITH THE INSPECTOR GENERAL AS
THEY GO AND MONITOR OUR PROCESS
WHICH THEY CURRENTLY DO A AND
WILL CONTINUE TO DO. ONE THING
WE DO KNOW IS THAT OUR FUNCTIONS
ARE SEPARATE AND DISTINCT- AS
SUCH YOU KNOW WE DO THE
INVESTIGATIONS OF THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL'S OFFICE IS THE ONE THAT
MONITORS THOSE. AND SO BECAUSE
OF THAT IT'S NOT NECESSARILY
APPROPRIATE FOR US AS AN AGENCY
TO WEIGH IN ON WEIGH IN ON THE
LEVEL OF THE INSPECTOR GENERAL'S
OVERSIGHT- INSTEAD AGAIN WE
ALWAYS WORK COLLABORATIVELY WITH
THEM WITH WHATEVER DECISIONS ARE
MADE. IF YOU'RE JUST I GUESS
JUST A FOLLOW UP COMMENT EIGHT I
GUESS WHAT I WAS REALLY ASKING
IS HOW MUCH MORE ARE YOU WILLING
TO COLLABORATE WITH THEM YOU
KNOW IN TERMS OF. COMING UP
WITH- GREATER OVERSIGHT I JUST.
IF I'M THE ONLY ONE THAT'S-
LEANING INTO THE ELOISE
RECOMMENDATION THAT'S THAT'S
FUNNY BECAUSE IT'S A COMMITTEE
WITH MULTIPLE FOLKS HERE IN A
LARGE LEGISLATURE BUT- M.
PROJECT IN A LITTLE BIT I THINK
FROM. MY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
EXPERIENCE WHERE. WE RAN INTO A
LOT OF PAUL PROBLEMS WITH BOTH
GRIEVANCE ISSUES IN THE JAILS
AND ALSO WHISTLEBLOWER ISSUES
OUTSIDE OF THE JAILS IN THE
GENERAL ADMINISTRATION WHEN WE-
WHEN WE- ROUTED. THOSE
COMPLAINTS YOU KNOW BACK TO THE
SAME. ADMINISTRATION THAT THAT
SOME OF THE COMPLAINTS WERE
DIRECTED AT IT SO. I JUST WANTED
TO EXPRESS- YOU KNOW SOME-
ALIGNMENT ON MY PART WITH WITH
THE A LITTLE L. L. A. O.'S
POSITION I AM NOT SETTLED ON
WHAT EXACTLY SHOULD BE DONE YET
BUT- THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I
JUST WANT. TO GET THAT OUT- AND
SECRETARY I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOU- ASKING THOSE QUESTIONS
BECAUSE- YOU KNOW THERE BEEN
ONGOING ISSUES AT CDC ARE- AN
INDEPENDENT OVERSIGHT HAS BEEN
FOUND TO BE VERY IMPORTANT AND
CRITICAL- WE'VE SEEN TIME AND
TIME AGAIN THAT ARE ASKING
ENTITIES TO OVERSEE THEMSELVES
DOESN'T ALWAYS WORK- ESPECIALLY
IN PARTICULAR WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND CORRECTIONS EVEN
WHEN ALL PARTIES ARE. VERY WELL
INTENTIONED- BUT THIS DOESN'T
WORK SO WE CAN SEE THAT CDCR IS
MOVING IN IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION- THIS IS A NEW PROCESS
HOPEFULLY THERE'S AN IMPROVEMENT
OVER IT- RIGHT I DO HAVE SOME
SPECIFIC. QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT-
FIRST WITH THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL- IF YOU COULD RESPOND
TO. WHAT DO YOU HAVE ANY
CONCERNS YOU HAVE WITH THIS NEW
PROCESS- AND IS YOUR OVERSIGHT-
TAILORED TOWARDS THE AREAS THAT
ARE GOING TO BE COVERED- AND DO
YOU. SEE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
NECESSARY FOR YOUR OFFICE TO
MONITOR THIS NEW PROCESS. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION- IN
REGARDS TO THE DEPARTMENT'S NEWS
NEW PROCESS I'M THE ONLY DOES
COMMEND THEM FOR COMING UP WITH
A NEW PROCESS. IN RESPONSE TO
SEVERAL OF OUR REPORTS IN THE
LAST FEW YEARS WHICH HAS BEEN A
ESSENTIALLY INDICATED THAT THAT
THE PROCESS THAT WAS IN PLACE
REGARDING STAFF COMPLAINTS ANY
GRIEVANCES I'M WAS NOT WORKING
I'M AS WELL AS IT SHOULD HOUSE.
EXCUSE ME I'M OFFICE DOES BUILD
A LOT OF LAYERS OF LAYERS OF
REVIEW- IT DOES NEED SOME OF OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS WHICH INCLUDED
REMOVING THE INITIAL SCREENING
PROCESS FROM THE PRISONS AND
TAKING THOSE OUT OF THE PRESENT
AND SENDING THEM TO A
CENTRALIZED SCREENING TEAM- THE-
I. D. DOESN'T PLAN ON MONITORING
THAT PROCESS TO ENSURE THAT
THOSE DECISIONS ARE MADE-
PROPERLY AND CONSISTENTLY I'M AS
THERE IS AN ALLEGATION- DECISION
INDEX THAT COULD BE SUBJECT TO
SOME DISCRETION BY THE
INDIVIDUAL ANALYST REVIEWING
THESE- COMPLAINTS. THAT ARE
BEING RECEIVED SO WE DO IT WE DO
COMMEND THE DEPARTMENT FOR
COMING UP WITH THE NEW PROCESS
BUT AS WITH ANY NEW PROCESS-
THERE IS GOING TO BE AN
IMPLEMENTATION PHASE. AND THERE
WILL BE UPS AND DOWNS AND WE ARE
HOPEFUL THAT WITH OUR MONITORING
WE ARE ABLE TO PROVIDE. TIMELY
FEEDBACK TO THE DEPARTMENT SO
THEY CAN AVOID SOME OF THE
PITFALLS THAT- WE'VE SEEN WHAT
THE PROCESS THAT WAS PUT IN
PLACE- OVER THE LAST YEAR YEAR
AND A HALF THAT TEAM'S INQUIRY
PROCESS- WE DID FIND SEVERAL
FAULT AND NOT THAT WE REPORTED
LAST YEAR. AND INCLUDING A
NUMBER OF- INCARCERATED PERSONS
GRIEVANCES REMAINING AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL AND SOME OF THE MOST
SERIOUS ONES NOT BEING
INVESTIGATED- BY AN OUTSIDE
OUTSIDE OF THE INSTITUTION
ENTITY- IN REGARDS TO ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES- OUR PROPOSAL IS
REQUESTING WHAT WE BELIEVE IS
OPERATIONALLY FEASIBLE. WE ARE
REQUESTING WHAT ARE AGENCY WHICH
IS MUCH MUCH SMALLER THAN THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS-
HUNDRED LESS THAN A HUNDRED
FORTY- PEOPLE WE WOULD LIKE TO
GET WHAT'S OPERATIONAL FEASIBLE
FOR US AND WE BELIEVE WHAT OUR
REQUEST IS ASKING FOR WILL ALLOW
US TO START THAT MONITORING
PROCESS RIGHT AWAY. AND THEN
WILL CONTINUE TO EVOLVE AND WILL
CONTINUE TO GROW- AND ASK FOR
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES AS
NECESSARY BUT RIGHT NOW WHAT
WE'VE ASKED FOR IT DOES GIVE US.
A WINDOW INTO THE PROCESS-
OVERSIGHT NECESSARILY LOOK FOR
EVERY SINGLE MISTAKE WHAT WE DO
LOOK FOR IS A WEAKNESS IN THE
PROCESS AND WE MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS IN REGARDS TO
THOSE WEAKNESSES SO THE
DEPARTMENT CAN FIX THEIR- LAW
ALL THE PROCESS. WE BELIEVE WHAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR SUFFICIENT
TICKET TO GET A HANDLE ON THAT
AND TO START THE MONITORING
PROCESS AS SOON AS THE- AS SOON
AS WE CAN GET THE APPROPRIATE
AMOUNT OF STAFFING TO DO THAT. I
JUST HAVE ONE SORT OF FOLLOW UP-
THE L. L. IS OFFICE- MADE SOME
SPECIFIC- OR RAISE SOME SPECIFIC
IDEAS- WITH REGARDS TO THE
EXPECTATION THAT WE SHOULD- THE
WE COULD HAVE. WHETHER WE
MONITOR MORE OF THE COMPLAINTS-
OR ALL THE COMPLAINTS VERSUS
THIRTY PERCENT- FOR THE QUALITY
OF THE- LOCAL IN CURRY'S OF
WHETHER THAT WE SHOULD HAVE THEY
SHOULD WE SHOULD MONITOR THE
REPORTS OR MONITOR THE INQUIRIES
THAT ARE BEING MADE. DO YOU HAVE
ANY THOUGHTS ON THOSE- FINANCIAL. I'M SORRY TO THE O. I. G. YES. IN REGARDS TO THE LOCAL
ENQUIRIES OUT. ONCE WE REVIEW
THE PROPOSALS PUT FORTH BY CDCR
WE REALIZED THERE WAS A LARGE
NUMBER OF ENQUIRIES THAT WE'RE
GOING BACK TO THE LOCAL
DESIGNATED AND INVESTIGATORS- WE
HAVE GONE BACK TO THE TABLE AND-
WE'VE REACHED OUT AND FINANCES-
WE'VE DISCUSSED WITH THEM OUR
CONCERN. THE ADMINISTRATION IS
SUPPORTIVE AND I BELIEVE THAT WE
WILL BE CONTINUING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS TO DETERMINE WHAT
RESOURCES ARE APPROPRIATE FOR US
TO. MONITOR THE ENQUIRIES AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. IN REGARDS TO THE
30% VERSUS A HUNDRED PERCENT. WE
BELIEVE 30% IS SUFFICIENT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IS VERY HIGH
VOLUME OF CASES- AND WE BELIEVE
30% IS GOING TO BE- APPROPRIATE
FOR US TO BE ABLE TO DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT THE PROCESS IS
ACTUALLY. OUT WORKING AND
WHETHER THE DEPARTMENT IS
FOLLOWING THEIR NEWLY
IMPLEMENTED REGULATIONS. AND DO
YOU HAVE ALREADY AN IDEA AS TO
HOW YOU'RE GOING TO SELECT THOSE
30% OR- ARE IN. AT THIS POINT
THE PROCESS THAT WE'VE. WE'VE
KIND OF PUT TOGETHER AND
SKETCHED OUT IS THAT WE WILL DO
A RANDOM SELECTION AND WE WILL
JUST LOOK AT THE- CASES THAT ARE
GOING TO THAT THE- ALLEGATION
INVESTIGATION UNIT DOES THE
COMPLEX CASES WILL ALSO LOOK AT
THE CASES THAT ARE BEING SENT
BACK. TO THE INSTITUTIONS TO THE
LOCALLY DESIGNATED INVESTIGATORS
TO DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT THE
- DECISIONS ARE BEING MADE I
CONSISTENTLY BY THE CENTRALIZED
SCREENING TEAM. OKAY EARN THANK
. ARE JUST TWO OF US MISS MILLER
IF YOU COULD RESPOND TO AGAIN TO
THE ISSUE THAT- OF MOST OF THE
ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF MISCONDUCT
WILL CONTINUE TO BE HANDLED AT
THE PRESENT LEVEL- WHICH HAS
BEEN A CONCERN THAT WE HAVE
RAISED IN THE PAST- ARE THERE
ANY ADDITIONAL STEPS- THAT YOU
LOOK TO TAKE TO ENSURE QUALITY
AND INDEPENDENCE. THANK YOU FOR
THAT QUESTION MADAM CHAIR IN
INDEED THERE IS- SOME ADDITIONAL
STEPS THAT WE'RE TAKING OF
COURSE AS SPOKEN ABOUT WE HAVE
CENTRALIZED SCREENING WHICH
MEANS THAT WE WILL BE HAVING
EVERY SINGLE ALLEGATION GOES
THROUGH THAT CENTRALIZED
SCREENING PROCESS. AND THAT
MEANS THAT WE WILL HAVE
CONSISTENCY AND MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE GETTING THEM TO THE RIGHT
PLACE WHEN WE TALK ABOUT WHAT
GOES BACK TO THE LOCAL
INSTITUTION THE OTHER THING THAT
WE'RE DOING SO BEFORE IF
SOMETHING WENT BACK TO THE LOCAL
INSTITUTION TO BE ADDRESSED. IT
WAS NEVER SEEN AGAIN BY THE
OFFICE OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS OR
ANYBODY ELSE IN LAST HIRING
AUTHORITY FELT LIKE IT NEEDED TO
GO TO THE OFFICE OF INTERNAL
AFFAIRS. BUT BECAUSE WE
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
GETTING THE STAFF COMPLAINTS
ANSWERED THOROUGHLY COMPLETELY
WITHOUT A BIAS WE NOW WITH THIS
NEW PROCESS WILL REQUIRE THAT
ONCE THAT LOCAL PROCESSES DONE.
THAT REPORT HAS TO COME TO THE
OFFICE OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS AND
THE SAME MANAGERS THAT ARE
REVIEWING THE INVESTIGATIONS
THAT ARE BEING DONE BY- I AIN'T
WILL ALSO BE. LOCAL WORRIES BY
THE INSTITUTE. THOSE MANAGERS
ARE TO REVIEW FOR THE SAME
STANDARDS THAT THEY'RE LOOKING
FOR WITH THEIR INVESTIGATORS IN
ADDITION TO THAT IF THEY SEE
CONCERNS THEY CAN EITHER SEND IT
BACK AND ASK FOR ADDITIONAL IN
QUERY WORK. OR THEY MAY DECIDE
TO KEEP IT IN THE OFFICE OF
INTERNAL AFFAIRS AND PUT IT
THROUGH. A MORE FORMAL FULL
INVESTIGATION PROCESS IF THEY
BELIEVE THAT THAT'S WHAT'S
APPROPRIATE. AND THEN FINALLY
THE THIRD THING THAT WE'VE THAT
WE'VE DONE IS WE HAVE CREATED A
CENTRALIZED DATABASE FOR EVERY
SINGLE ALLEGATION OF STAFF
MISCONDUCT. AND THAT REALLY
GIVES US AS A DEPARTMENT THE
ABILITY TO LOOK AT TRENDS
IDENTIFY IF THERE'S A PARTICULAR
STAFF MEMBER THAT HAS A LARGE
NUMBER OF ALLEGATIONS AGAINST
THEM. WHETHER OR NOT THERE'S A
PARTICULAR LOCATION OR
INSTITUTION THAT IS SEEMS TO BE
HAVING MULTIPLE ISSUES- SO WE'RE
ABLE TO LOOK AT SYSTEMIC ISSUES
AND TRENDS AND REALLY DIVE DOWN
INTO THAT AS WELL SOMETHING WE
NEVER HAD BEFORE. SO WE REALLY
FEEL LIKE THOSE THREE THINGS
TOGETHER ARE GOING TO. HELP US
NOT ONLY WITH THE ENTIRE PROCESS
BUT ALSO. WE MONITOR THAT WORK
THAT YOU DONE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
RECOGNIZING THAT. FOR THOSE
LESSER AND LESS SERIOUS
ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF MISCONDUCT
IT'S MORE APPROPRIATE FOR IT TO
BE ADDRESSED AT THE INSTITUTION
AND TO BE AND FOR THE INCREASE
TO HAPPEN AT THE INSTITUTION.
BUT IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT THAT WE
TAKE A LOOK AT IT MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'VE DONE WHAT THEY NEED TO
DO TO REALLY GET TO THE HEART OF
THE MATTER. AND PROVIDE THE
FACTS NEEDED FOR HIRING
AUTHORITY TO MAKE A GOOD
DECISION. OKAY THANK YOU WELL WE
LOOK FORWARD TO THIS NEW
PROCESS- WE WELCOME THE
ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT THAT
TRANSPARENCY. AND THE
OPPORTUNITY IT ALSO IS AN
OPPORTUNITY HIGHLIGHT PROGRESS.
THAT WILL BE MADE SO- I'M SORRY
. AT THE END- OKAY DISEASES OKAY
OF THE L. EIGHT L. A- DEPART
MISSED ON. THANK YOU MA'AM JUST
ONE TO. MAKE A QUICK
CLARIFICATION- BECAUSE I THINK
OUR RECOMMENDATION MAY HAVE BEEN
MISS CHARACTERIZED OR
MISUNDERSTOOD IN THAT
CONVERSATION IS THAT ALRIGHT
WITH UNIFY YES BY YOU SEE THAT
RIGHT IF I'M SORRY FIGHT
CONTRIBUTED TO THAT NO NO I
DON'T. I DON'T KNOW THAT THAT'S
THE CASE. IT IS A VERY
COMPLICATED SYSTEM- TO
UNDERSTAND AND THERE'S A LOT OF
MOVING PIECES I'M AND I AM NOT
NOT SETTING CLEARLY BUT- SO
UNDER DAY AND THERE'S TWO
PROPOSALS. THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
AND THAT'S SORT OF HOW THEY FIT
TOGETHER WHICH ALSO MAKES IT
COMPLICATED SO- SO UNDER CDC
OURS PROPOSAL. BERMAN IS
EXPECTING TO ABOUT TWO AND
TWENTY. THOUSAND CLAIMS ANNUALLY
FROM VARIOUS SOURCES OF VARIOUS
TYPES OF CLAIMS. UNDER THE EIGHT
AND UNDER AND- WITHIN THAT
PROPOSAL CDCR INDICATES THAT-
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND OF THEM WOULD BE
REGULAR GRIEVANCES- AND THEN
BEYOND THAT THE REST OF THE
CLAIMS OUR REQUEST FOR
REASONABLE ACCOMMODATION UNDER
THAT AMERICA AND- AMERICANS WITH
DISABILITIES ACT- HEALTH CARE
GRIEVANCES. AND OTHER CLAIMS
SUBMITTED BY. ACCORDING TO
MONITOR 30% OF THE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND REGULAR
GRIEVANCES AND SO WE'RE JUST
ASKING WHETHER THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD WANT THEM TO MONITOR 30%
OF ALL TYPES OF ALL TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY THOUSAND CLAIMS AS
OPPOSED TO JUST THAT ONE TYPE- I
THINK IT WAS MAYBE STATED THAT
WE WERE SUGGESTING THAT- I. G.
B. RESOURCE TO. MONITOR A 100%
OF CLAIMS BUT WE'RE JUST
SUGGESTING THAT PERHAPS THE 30%
SHOULD APPLY OR SOME OTHER
PERCENT TO A FULL SPECTRUM OF
CLAIMS- BECAUSE BASED ON THE
CURRENT LEVEL OF RESOURCES. IF
YOU WERE TO APPLY THOSE
RESOURCES TO THE FULL TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND CLAIMS
THEY'D ONLY BE ABLE TO MONITOR.
ABOUT 20% OF CLAIMS SO I JUST
WANTED TO CLARIFY THAT THANK YOU
OKAY GREAT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
THANK YOU READY TO MOVE ON-
COLLEAGUES ANY FINAL QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. OKAY YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR- FOR YOUR
COMMENTS AND PRESENTATIONS THE
NEXT ISSUE IS NUMBER TWO
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES FOR THE
OFFICE OF THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
AND WE HAVE THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE. GOOD MORNING ONCE
AGAIN RAMCHARAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AMRIK SINGH INSPECTOR
GENERAL. OUR PROPOSAL FOR
MEDICAL INSPECTION UNIT IS
REQUESTING FUNDING FOR EIGHTEEN
POSITIONS IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVEN WE BEGAN CONDUCTING
INSPECT INSPECTIONS OF THE
MEDICAL CARE AT STATE PRISONS
AND IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN WE
WERE GIVEN STATUTORY AUTHORITY
TO CONDUCT OBJECTIVE CLINICALLY
APPROPRIATE. AND METRIC ORIENTED
MEDICAL INSPECTIONS TO REVIEW
THE DELIVERY OF MEDICAL CARE AT
EACH PRESENT. OUR INSPECTIONS.
ARE COMPLETED IN CYCLE ANY CYCLE
TAKES ABOUT THREE TO THREE AND A
HALF YEARS TO COMPLETE. THE
INSPECTION PROCESS ENTAILS
MULTIPLE- MULTIPLE PARKS- WE
COLLECT DATA FROM THE DEPARTMENT
WE PERFORM AN ANALYSIS OF THAT
DATA AND CREATED A SAMPLE. FOR
FURTHER REVIEW IN TESTING AND WE
HAVE CLINICAL CASE REVIEW OF
THAT SAMPLE TO DETERMINE IF THE
CARE IS CONSISTENT WITH
PROFESSIONAL STANDARDS WE
CONDUCT COMPLIANCE REVIEW OF THE
DOCUMENTATION TO DETERMINE IF
THE CARE IS CONSISTENT WITH
DEPARTMENTAL POLICY AND THEN WE
DO ON SITE TESTING AND THE
PROVISION OF CARE. WE TAKE ALL
OF THIS INFORMATION THAT IS
OBTAINED AND OBSERVE AND WE
REVIEW IT WE COMPLETE OUR
TESTING ON THAT DETERMINE THE
ACCURACY AND THEN WE PREPARE
WRITTEN REPORTS IT IS THAT
LENGTHY PROCESS TO CONDUCT ALL
OF THE STEPS WHICH TAKES A
COURSE OF SEVERAL MONTHS. SINCE
TWO AND ELEVEN THERE HAVE BEEN
MANY CHANGES IN THE MEDICAL CARE
OF INCARCERATED PERSONS ARE
THERE HAVE BEEN SUBSTANCE ABUSE
PROGRAMS AT TELEHEALTH SERVICE
AND- THERE'S A HEPATITIS C.
TREATMENT PROGRAM HOSPICE. UNIT
JUST TO NAME A FEW THAT HAVE
BEEN IMPLEMENTED SINCE THAT
TIME. OUR CURRENT PROPOSAL IS
SEEKING TO ACHIEVE OUR NUMBER OF
THINGS FIRST IT. TO CREATE A
MANAGEMENT STRUCTURE THAT WAS
NEVER ESTABLISHED- IN OUR
MEDICAL INSPECTION UNITS
SPECIFICALLY OR SEEKING A
SUPERVISOR FOR OUR NURSING OUR
CLASSIFICATIONS. THANK WE WILL
NEED TO A OUR CURRENT STAFF WITH
THE SUFFICIENT NUMBER OF
CLINICAL STAFF TO SPEED UP OUR
INSPECTION CYCLE WITH THE
ADDITIONAL STAFF WE BELIEVE WE
WILL BE ABLE TO COMPLETE OUR
INSPECTIONS WITHIN A TWO YEAR
CYCLE AS OPPOSED TO THE CURRENT
THREE TO THREE AND A HALF YEARS
. FINALLY THIS- PROPOSAL ALSO
PROPERLY ALIGNED STAFF TO
COMPLETE THE COMPACT. DATA
SAMPLING AND SORTING OF
HEALTHCARE RELATED DATA THAT'S
RECEIVED FROM THE DEPARTMENT
WHICH BASICALLY FORMS THE
FOUNDATION OF OUR REVIEWS. THE
COLOR OF OUR REFUSES TO PROVIDE
NEUTRAL AND OBJECTIVE- REVIEW OF
THE HEALTH CARE- THAT'S PROVIDED
IN IN THE INSTITUTIONAL SETTING.
WE PROVIDE A WINDOW TO THE
PUBLIC INTO THE CARE THAT'S
PROVIDED TO THE INCARCERATED
PERSONS. AND WE PROVIDE REPORTS
THAT ARE BENEFICIAL TO THE
STAKEHOLDERS. I REQUEST FOR
THESE EIGHTEEN POSITIONS IS
BASED ON DATA THAT WE OBTAINED
FROM OUR CURRENT CYCLE WHICH IS
CYCLE SIX WHICH IS STILL ONGOING
AT THE TIME OF OUR REQUEST. WE
HAD ONLY COMPLETED ABOUT- WITH
COMPLETE TWELVE CONSTRUCTIONS OF
THE THIRTY FOUR. INSTITUTIONS
AND FOR THESE REASONS WE BELIEVE
THAT WE NEED ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES- WE ANTICIPATE DOING
MORE TIME KEEPING TO GATHER MORE
DATA. ON TO. LIKELY SUBMIT A
FUTURE PROPOSAL FOR ONGOING
RESOURCES BUT AT THIS TIME WE
BELIEVE IF WE CAN GET THE
EIGHTEEN POSITIONS- STARTED WE
WILL BE ABLE TO- SHORTEN OUR
INSPECTION CYCLE. AND PROVIDE
MORE TIMELY REPORTS TO THE IT
STAKEHOLDERS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND I AM OPEN FOR
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU- THE FINAL
PLEASE. UGH MORE BRAND CODY I
JUST ECHO AND THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL'S COMMENTS- THE
MINISTRATION IS COMMITTED TO
MAKING SURE THAT THE- I. G. HAS
RESOURCES TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN
INCREASING THE FREQUENCY OF ITS
MEDICAL INSPECTIONS OF CDCR
INSTITUTIONS AND ANTICIPATES
RETURNED TO THE LEGISLATURE
WILLFUL PROPOSAL TO MAKE
PERMANENT RESOURCES AVAILABLE
FOR THE O. I. G. ONCE- MORE
COMPREHENSIVE DATA SO IT BECOMES
AVAILABLE. OKAY I'M I'M SORRY-
MR- COULD COULD TAKE IS THAT HOW
YOU PRONOUNCE IT. YES ORTEGA
CODY CODY I'M SORRY MR CODY- THE
COULD YOU JUST A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT. MOVING TO. OR PERMANENT
RESOURCES. PERSONALLY SO AS
INSPECTOR GENERAL MENTIONED AT
THE TIME BUT THE PROPOSAL WAS
REVIEWED- THERE WERE IN THE
MIDDLE OF- INSPECTION CYCLE SIX
AND THEY HAD TWELVE- TWELVE
INSTITUTIONS THAT THEY COMPLETED
INSPECTIONS FOR- AND- DURING
DURING THAT TIME BUT THEY ALSO
HAD CHALLENGES WITH- KIND OF
CONDUCT A MEDICAL INSPECTIONS IN
THE MIDST OF A- THE- THE
PANDEMIC- AN EMPLOYMENT
COMPONENT AT A NEW TIME KEEPING
SYSTEM TO TRACK THE RESOURCES.
SO AS THEY THEY COMPLETE THE
SPIN CYCLE THIRD THIRD- WORK
WORK WE HAVE PROVIDED RESOURCE
ON A- TEMPORARY BASIS- FOR THREE
YEARS AND THEN WE ANTICIPATE
THAT WE WILL. WORK WITH WERE
MORE COURSE AND- I. G. AND THE
LEGISLATURE MOVING FORWARD- WHAT
ONCE MORE DATA IS AVAILABLE
ATTEMPT TO FIND PERMANENT.
PERMANENT RESOURCES FOR THE. THE
MEDICAL INSPECTION UNIT. OKAY
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MUCH- THE L.
A. OPEN. GOOD MORNING MAN
CHAIRMAN SENATOR MY NAME'S
ORLANDO SAN WITH THE A. L. WE DO
NOT REYES CONCERN. AT THIS TIME
WITH THE ALWAYS. SUPERBOWL THANK
YOU. HEY MISTER ANSWER THOSE
MISTER. GOOD MISTER SANCHEZ
VENTURES OKAY. THANK YOU- I
JUST- A FOLLOW UP QUESTION- TO
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL ARE YOU
TALKED ABOUT ONE OF YOUR
PROPOSALS- BUT YOU DIDN'T ABOUT
THE UNIT OCI. UNIFEM DEATH. YES
AMRIK SINGH INSPECTOR GENERAL I
I'M SORRY MADAM CHAIR I EAT THAT
WAS A COMPLETE OVERSIGHT ON MY
PART I'M LOOKING AT MY SET OF
NOTES- IT. IF OMITTED I WOULD
LIKE TO GIVE JUST A VERY BRIEF
BRIEF OVERSIGHT OVERVIEW OF WHAT
WE ARE REQUESTING FOR OUR
OVERSIGHT. HE ROBIN INTAKE UNIT
. YES PLEASE. THANK YOU. THE
PROPOSAL FOR THIS UNIT- WHICH WE
CALL OCI- IT'S TO ADDRESS
INCREASED WORKLOAD WE ARE
REQUESTING TWO POSITIONS ARE OCI
UNIT HAS A VARIETY OF
RESPONSIBILITIES- WHICH INCLUDES
WARNING TO PROTECT READING
BLUEPRINTS MONITORING OF THE
DEPARTMENT AND ON CALIFORNIA
REHABILITATION OVERSIGHT BOARD-
RESPONSIBILITIES BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY WE DO GET A NUMBER
OF COMPLAINTS WE RECEIVE IN
REVIEW COMPLAINTS THAT ARE
RECEIVED FROM INCARCERATED
PERSONS AND THE GENERAL PUBLIC
IN THE LAST FOUR YEARS OUR
COMPLAINTS HAVE DOUBLED HOWEVER
OUR STAFFING HAS REMAINED THE
SAME SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND
ELEVEN. IN ORDER TO KEEP UP WITH
OUR WORKLOAD WE HAVE HAD TO BE
DRAGGED UP TO SEVEN STAFF
MEMBERS AT ANY GIVEN TIME TO
ASSESS- THE COMPLAINTS THAT WE
RECEIVED AND TO ASSIST THE UNIT
FROM NOT FALLING FAR BEHIND AND
HAVING A BACKLOG OF COMPLAINTS
RECEIPT WE HAVE ALSO
HISTORICALLY RELIED ON A NUMBER
OF STUDENTS JUST DANCE WHO HAVE
BEEN GREAT HOWEVER WE DO NEED TO
RELY ON A PERMANENT WORKFORCE.
WE ARE ASKING THAT THE ADDITION
OF TO ASSOCIATE DEPUTY INSPECTOR
GENERALS- ARE ARE COMMITTED FOR
OUR UNIT BECAUSE THEY WILL HELP
ASSIST US TO HANDLE THE
INCREASED VOLUME OF COMPLAINTS
ON THIS CLASSIFICATION IS MORE
SKILLED THAN AN ANALYST AND THEY
WILL BE ABLE TO HANDLE SOME OF
THE MORE COMPLEX CASES THAT WE
RECEIVE- COMPLAINTS THAT WE
RECEIVE SOME WHICH I CAN TAKE UP
TO TWO. HOURS TO REVIEW. THIS IS
ALSO A POSITION THAT I WE BE
TRAIN. A TRAINING IN BY. AS IT
HELP TO OUR STAFF MEMBERS AND IT
WILL HELP US TO. OUR RECRUITING
RETAIN WELL QUALIFIED PEOPLE
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND I AM ALSO
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS IN
REGARDS TO THIS PROPOSAL. GREAT
AND I HAVE. ONE MORE OF A-
MISSING BUT DO YOU HAVE ANY IDEA
HERE- DICKS FACT THE NUMBER OF
COMPLAINTS- TO CONTINUE TO
INCREASE- AND DO YOU WHAT ARE
YOUR THOUGHTS ABOUT WHY. IT IS
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
COMPLAINTS. ALL. REYES INSPECTOR
GENERAL I HATE I BELIEVE THE
NUMBER HAVE COME COMPLAINTS HAVE
INCREASED- WE'VE GOTTEN MORE-
COUNTLESS IN INFORMATION OUT
INTO THE INSTITUTIONS WE OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS HAVE
GOTTEN POSTERS PUT INTO EACH OF
THE INSTITUTIONS AN EIGHT
HUNDRED NUMBER WE HAVE A
WEBSITE- SO WE'VE ACTUALLY GONE
OUT INTO THE INSTITUTIONS TO
INCARCERATED PERSONS NOW THAT
THEIR- THEY DO HAVE A CHANNEL
AVAILABLE TO THEM. IF THEY ARE
ARE UNABLE TO OR OR WITH OR JUST
NEED AN EXTRA LAYER OF OVER
SOMEONE TO LOOK INTO THEIR AND
SO WE'VE PROVIDED A NUMBER OF
RESOURCES TO THE GEERAL PUBLIC
AND TO THE INCARCERATED
POPULATION AND I BELIEVE NOW
THAT THEY HAVE- HAVE THE ACCESS
TO MAKE COMPLAINTS TO DIRECTLY
TO THE O. I. G. AT LEAST THIS
IS. PART OF THE- A REASON WHY
ARE COMPLETE HAVE HAVE DOUBLED
IN LAST FOUR YEARS. OKAY GOOD I
MEAN IT'S GOOD AND HOPEFULLY
THAT LEADS TO THE KIND OF
CHANGES THAT WE NEED TO AVOID
THE COMPLAINTS IN THE FUTURE-
OKAY ZANZA. COLLEAGUES IN THE
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS YES
SENATOR NEWMAN THANK YOU MEASURE
SO A KEY QUESTION ON- THE
MEDICAL INSPECTION UNIT
SPECIFICALLY THE CYCLE THAT THE
NOTE- THE NOTES. NOTE THAT IT
TAKES A PROBABLY THREE AND A
HALF THREE TO THREE TO HAVE
YEARS TO COMPLETE THE FULL CYCLE
OF MEDICAL INSPECTIONS- SO. WHY
SO LONG IT SEEMS LIKE A VERY
LONG TIME- AND IS IT HOW DOES
THAT COMPARE TO BEST PRACTICES
IN OTHER STATES IF SOMEBODY
KNOWS. MAYBE MR CODY RATIONING.
WHO WOULD WHO WOULD LIKE TO- IS
BACK TO GENERAL MISSING I ALL
START OFF WITH THAT- THE PROCESS
TAKES A LONG TIME BECAUSE OF THE
VOLUME OF DATA THAT WE RECEIVE
AND GOING THROUGH THE DATA TO
CREATE A SAMPLE SIZE- WE HAVE WE
REALLY GO THROUGH THE- REVIEWS
THESE CASE REVIEWS THAT WE DO
OUR VERY THOROUGHLY. AND TIMELY
THERE IS REALLY NO MANDATE TO
COMPLETE THESE REVIEWS IN A
CERTAIN TIME ON THERE ISN'T A
SPEED REQUIREMENTS- BUT WHAT WE
DO IS WE HAVE TO LOOK DO
DETAILED REVIEWS OF THE SAMPLE
THAT WE GET. THE DATA THAT WE
GET A REASONABLE SAMPLE AND THEN
WE HAVE CLINICIANS THAT REVIEWED
THE DOCUMENTATION WE HAVE WE
LOOK AT STANDARD OF CARE WE LOOK
AT DEPARTMENT POLICY WE LOOK AT
BEN ON SITE AND HOW HE CARRIES
BEING HANDLED ON SITE SO THERE'S
A NUMBER OF STEPS AND IT TAKES
OF COURSE OF SEVERAL MONTHS TO
GET THROUGH AN INSPECTION THESE-
INDICATOR QUESTIONS THAT WE HAVE
TO ANSWER. TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
ACCURATE- WE DO A LOT OF BACK
AND- ACCURACY CHECKS AS WELL
BECAUSE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE PROVIDING DATA THAT
IS RELIABLE AND INFORMATION THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS CAN RELY ON I'M SO
THAT'S PART OF THE REASON WHY IT
TAKES A VERY LENGTHY AMOUNT OF
TIME. AND OF COURSE THE REPORT
WRITING ALSO ADDS AN EXTRA LAYER
OF A NUMBER OF DAYS- CLINICIANS
AREN'T NECESSARILY REPORT
WRITERS AND SO IT DOES TAKE OUR
EDITORS- ALONG WITH OUR
CLINICIANS TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE READABLE REPORTS THAT ARE
ACTUALLY- PROVIDING INFORMATION
THAT IS BENEFICIAL. THANK YOU
VERY SERVICES CHATHAM INTO AGAIN
SEEMS TO ME THREE HAVE YEARS IS
QUITE A LONG TIME AND THE TIME
YOU COULD HAVE SUBSTANTIAL
CHANGES BOTH THE PERSONAL BUT
ALSO. PROCESS AND- PRESS OF.
THERE IS SOME THOUGHT MIGHT BE
GIVEN TO TRYING TO COMPRESS THE
TIME LINE IN ORDER TO MAKE FINE
USED AND WILL. IT WHATEVER PRICE
YOU WHATEVER ABOUT COME OUT OF
THAT- IN WAYS THAT MAKE SENSE
OTHERWISE IT IT SEEMS LIKE YOU
GET STUCK IN A BIT OF A LOOP.
WHO MISS. MISSING DO YOU HAVE
ANY OF SUGGESTIONS ON HOW TO
SPEED THAT UP. THAT IS THE BASIS
FOR OUR PROPOSAL A PRIMARILY
BECAUSE WE WANT TO SPEED UP
THESE THESE INSPECTIONS WE WANT
TO SPEED UP THE CYCLES- WE HAD
STAKEHOLDERS ACTUALLY REACH OUT
AND ASK FOR US TO TRY AND SPEED
UP THIS PROCESS- AND- WE
RECOGNIZE THAT WE RECOGNIZE THAT
PROVIDING MORE TIMELY
RECOMMENDATIONS AND INFORMATION
IS BENEFICIAL TO ALL- WHEN IT
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
PROVIDING MEDICAL CARE BUT I DO
WANT TO MAKE SURE I POINT OUT
THAT. IF THE O. I. G. EFFORT FOR
CLINICIANS OBSERVE SOMETHING AT
THE TIME OF OUR INSPECTION OR
THE TIME OF OUR REVIEWS THAT WE
FEEL NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED
IMMEDIATELY WE DO TAKE THAT TO
THE ATTENTION OF THE THAT DEPART
OF THE INSTITUTIONAL STAFF WE
MAKE SURE THAT IF THERE IS
ANYTHING- FOR EXAMPLE MEDICATION
MANAGEMENT OR ANYTHING THAT WE
REVIEW THAT WE FEEL NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED IMMEDIATELY WE DO LET
THE DEPARTMENT NOW SO WEAK WE
DON'T WAIT THREE TO THREE AND A
HALF YEARS TO SAY. BY THE WAY
TWO YEARS AGO THIS HAPPENED WE
ENSURE. THAT THAT INFORMATION IS
TIMELY PROVIDED. IF AB I GUESS
THAT'S YOU KNOW THE THREE HAVE
YEARS JUST CURRENT. ITERATION
WHAT'S THE ASPIRATION WHAT ARE
WE WORKING TOWARD. I WAS LESS
THAN THREE AND A HALF YEARS BUT
DID YOU KNOW THERE SHOULD BE. A
STANDARD GOAL YOU'RE WORKING
TOWARD WHICH IS THE BOTTOM OUT
OF TIME FOR TURN AROUND IN THIS
COUNTRY FORGE. MISSING YES YES
WE ARE- THE GOAL IS TO HEAR
ABOUT IT THIS PROPOSAL. IS
HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN. MOVE TO A
TWO YEAR PROCESS AS OPPOSED TO
THREE TO THREE AND A HALF YEARS
. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK
YOU. OKAY I THINK THAT'S IT FOR
THIS ISSUE- THANK YOU ALL AGAIN
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATIONS
WE MOVE ON TO ISSUE THREE AND
THIS IS THE AMERICANS WITH
DISABILITIES ACT FACILITIES
IMPROVEMENTS AND STAFFING AND WE
WILL START WITH A C. D. C. R.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS- MY NAME'S CHRIS LEAVES
ON THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR.
SAUDI PLANNING CONSTRUCTION AND
MANAGEMENT DIVISION. SCDC OUR
REQUEST TWENTY TWO POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND. FOR CONSTRUCTION OF
AMERICANS WITH DISABILITY ACT
ACCESSIBILITY IMPROVEMENTS AT
THE CALIFORNIA INSTITUTION FOR
MEN. CALIFORNIA INSTITUTION FOR
WOMEN- CALIFORNIA STATE PRISON
LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND THE
RICHARD J. DONOVAN CORRECTIONAL
FACILITY. AT THESE IMPROVEMENTS
WILL IMPLEMENT ADA TRANSITION
PLANS FOR THESE DISABILITY
PLACEMENT PROGRAM DESIGNATED
INSTITUTIONS- THESE TRANSITION
PLANS WERE DESIGNED TO PROVIDE
THE FACILITIES FOR A CURSORY
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
THAT PROVIDE THEM THE SAME
OPPORTUNITIES AS THOSE WITHOUT
DISABILITIES. SHE PLANS FOR
DEVELOPMENT PLAINTIFFS IN
ARMSTRONG FEDERAL CLASS ACTION
LAWSUIT. AND WITH THAT I'LL TURN
IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE GOT A
JERK WAS ON ON TO EXPLAIN THE
OTHER. THANK YOU. I'M SHARING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. HELLO MY NAME
S JOURNALISM ON THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR FACILITY SUPPORT IN
THE DIVISION OF ADULT
INSTITUTIONS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION. THE CDC OUR END
OF THE CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL
HEALTH CARE SERVICES ARE
REQUESTING FUNDING IN POSITIONS
TO SUPPORT MANDATED AMERICANS
WITH DISABILITIES ACT OR ADA
REMEDIAL MEASURES FOR
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES AT VARIOUS
INSTITUTIONS. CDCR CCHS IS
POLICIES INSURING CARS RATED
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
HAVE EQUAL ACCESS TO PROGRAMS
SERVICES AND ACTIVITIES
CONSISTENT WITH EIGHTY
REQUIREMENTS. WELL IN CURSORY
DID. PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
ARE OFTEN REQUIRE ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT AND ASSISTANCE FROM
STAFF. IT'S PROPOSAL PROVIDES
RESOURCES TO ENSURE CDCR IN CCHS
CAN CONTINUE TO PROVIDE A
CONSISTENT LEVEL OF CARE INFILL
ITS OBLIGATIONS TOWARDS THE
DISTANT BUT DISABLED POPULATION
MY COLLEAGUE KAMAL SINGH THE
ACTING DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
FACILITY OPERATIONS CORRECTIONAL
SERVICES BUT CCHS IN HIGH ARE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
RELATED TO THIS PROPOSAL. THANK
THANK YOU MISTER LOZANO- WILL
HAVE SOMEONE FROM FINANCE PLEASE
. IRAN YOU SHADOW DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. MINISTRATION SUPPORTS
THESE PROPOSALS TO PROVIDE
BETTER ACCESS AND THE NECESSARY
LEVEL OF SERVICES FOR THE
DISABLED INCARCERATED POPULATION
IN ADDITION THAT WILL ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT TO COMPLY WITH THE
REQUIREMENTS OF ARMSTRONG
TRANSITION PLAN. THANK YOU HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS OKAY
THANK YOU- THE LA OFFICE PLEASE. WE DON'T HAVE CONCERNS
SPECIFIC TO THESE TWO PROPOSALS
HOWEVER I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT
ONE OF THEM I DOES INVOLVE A
MODIFICATION TO PRESENT
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION RELEASED ON
FRIDAY A REPORT- ARTICULATING
ITS- ITS ANTICIPATED
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS OVER THE
NEXT TEN YEARS. SO WE'RE STILL
REVIEWING THAT REPORT- AND ARE
REVIEWING ALL INFRASTRUCTURE
MODIFICATION PROPOSALS IN THE
CONTEXT OF THE INFORMATION IN
THAT REPORT AND- WHEN WE REACH
RECOMMENDATIONS AND WE WILL CAN
COMMUNICATE THEM TO THE
COMMITTEE. SO THE EXPECTATION
THAT THESE ISSUES WILL BE
BROUGHT UP IN THAT REPORT. THE
EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHTY A NOT NOT
NECESSARILY EASY ISSUE
SPECIFICALLY BUT JUST- IS A
REPORT THAT CDCR RECENTLY
SUBMITTED TO THE LEGISLATURE IN
WHICH IT'S- PRAYER IDENTIFYING
AND PRIORITIZING- INFRASTRUCTURE
MODIFICATION AT- PRISONS THAT
IT'S EXPECTED PROJECTS THAT ARE
EXPECTED TO COST OVER FIVE
MILLION OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS.
AND SO WE WOULDN'T WANT A
SITUATION WHERE OUR OR- WE WOULD
LIKELY SEEK TO AVOID SITUATIONS
WHERE THAT- YOU KNOW A FEW YEARS
FROM NOW THE STATE IS GOING TO-
OR DEMONSTRATIONS GOING TO
PROPOSE. AB FUNDAMENTALLY
RENOVATING A FACILITY THAT WE
JUST ADDED ADA MODIFICATIONS TO-
SO THAT'S THE KIND OF THING
WE'RE JUST WE JUST WANT. TO LOOK
OUT FOR- FORECLOSE OFFICIAL FOR.
IN THE NEAR FUTURE. THAT KIND OF
LIKE TAKING A HOLISTIC LOOK AT
DIED. AT THOSE INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS AND THINKING ABOUT HOW
THESE- PROPOSED INFRASTRUCTURE
MODIFICATION PROJECTS AT. FIT
INTO THAT OVERALL PICTURE. AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING THANK
YOU MISS ON IT AND THAT WAS THE
WHOLE POINT OF ASKING FOR THE
PLAN IN THE FIRST PLACE. TIME
FOR CLOSURES BECAUSE IT IMPACTS
CAPITAL OUTLAYS- AND- RATES AND
SAID IT CENTER- THANK YOU FOR
THAT I JUST HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS- SHATTER DEPARTMENT
FINANCE WOULD YOU MIND IF I
RESPOND- OKAY SURE THANK YOU-
THESE INVESTMENTS ARE ESSENTIAL
TO MAINTAINING CORE COMPLIANCE
PROVIDE THE INCARCERATED PERSONS
WITH BETTER ACCESS WITHIN THESE
INSTITUTIONS. WITH THAT BEING
SAID THE ADMINISTRATION
UNDERSTANDS THE SENSITIVITY OR
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
INFRASTRUCTURE RESOURCES WITH
THE PRESENT POPULATION PROJECTED
TO DECLINE IN THE FUTURE YEARS
HOWEVER THIS IS JUST ONE
COMPONENT TO CONSIDER WHEN
LOOKING AT CLOSING I PERSONALLY
THINK IT'S UNWISE TO PIES
INFRASTRUCTURE SPENDING. GIVEN
CONSIDERABLE FUTURE UNCERTAINTY
AND A CRITICAL NEED FOR THESE
MODIFICATIONS EVEN AS THE
POPULATION DECLINES IN FUTURE
YEARS I WILL ALSO CONTINUE TO
AGE WHICH WILL LIKELY KEEP THE
DEMAND FOR THESE ADA. COMPLIANCE
CHANGES HI. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
IT WILL BE GOOD THOUGH TO
INCLUDE ALL OF THESE ISSUES AS
WE GO FORWARD WITH A PLAN- AFTER
THE PROPOSED PROJECTS AND
STAFFING INCREASES. HOW FAR IS
CDC ARE IN REACHING A FULL ADA
COMPLIANCE. ON THE DISABILITY
SIDE- WE WILL HAVE- A FUTURE-
BUDGET ASKS FOR- IMPROVEMENTS AT
EIGHT OR NINE OTHER
INSTITUTIONS- AND WE ANTICIPATE
THAT WILL- THOSE REQUESTS WILL
BE OVER SEVERAL YEARS AT ONE PM
AND ANNUAL. THANK SOME TIMING
IS- NOT NOT CRYSTAL CLEAR AT
THIS POINT. OKAY AND ARE THERE
OTHER STEPS ALONG THESE LINES AT
CDC ARE STILL NEEDS TO TAKE.
MISTER LEAF. THAT THAT HI WELL-
WE HAVE IDENTIFIED- YOU KNOW THE
BARRIERS AT AT EIGHT
INSTTUTIONS- WE ARE STILL-
DEVELOPING THE SCOPE FOR- AND
ALWAYS STAY PRESENT- IN THE
MEANTIME- YOU. WE HAVE MADE SOME
IMPROVEMENTS TO ADA
INFRASTRUCTURE THROUGH THE
HEALTHCARE FACILITY AND PREVENT
PROGRAM AS WELL AS- YOU KNOW
MINOR IMPROVEMENTS THAT CAN BE
DONE BY AND STUFF ARE
IMPLEMENTED. OKAY OKAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU EVERYONE VERY MUCH
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON NOW TO
THE NEXT ISSUE OF FOR WHICH IS
MENTAL HEALTH DATA ANALYSIS AND
IN FOR INFORMATICS. MMHM CDC ARE
PLENTY. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
JIM KERR RATE THIS IS THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR THE STATEWIDE
MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAM THE CDC
ARE STATEWIDE MENTAL HEALTH
PROGRAM IS REQUESTING FUNDING
AND POSITIONS TO SUPPORT
ADDITIONAL MENTAL HEALTH
REPORTING TASKS A NEW DATA
VALIDATION PROJECT RELATED TO
THE CONCORD AND TO ADDRESS
INCREASE RECORDING REQUIRES.
THESE RESOURCES WILL BE USED TO
SUPPORT THE STATE WIDE MENTAL
HEALTH PROGRAMS QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM. WHICH IS
THE UNIVERSE POSSIBLE FOR
MEASURING BOTH THE QUALITY OF
CARE PROVIDED TO PATIENTS. WHO
ARE PARTICIPATING IN THE MENTAL
HEALTH PROGRAM. AND IS NOW
RESPONSIBLE FOR MANAGEMENT OF
COMMON COURT APPROVED PROVISION
PROVISIONAL KEY INDICATORS.
PROVIDING LONG TERM STABLE TRAIN
STAFF TO COMPLETE THE COURT
REQUIRED DATA VERIFICATION
PROJECT. IS CRITICAL TO BALL DID
YOU HEAR ABOUT ALL PROGRAM'S
SUCCESS. IN THE MEETING
REQUIREMENTS FOR COMING COURT
CASE. AND ALSO ENSURING A LONG
TERM ABILITY TO USE DATA. FOR
MONITORING OF THE STATEWIDE
MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAM. I WAS
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERT HERE TODAY
AND WE ARE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE ON THE PROPOSAL. THANK YOU
. THANK YOU DR CART RIGHT- CAN
WE HAVE ANY COMMENTS FROM
FINANCE PLEASE. ALISON HEWITT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO
SPECIFIC COMMENT AT THIS TIME
BUT AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU- THRILLED OFFICE PLEASE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR WE DO NOT
RAISE ANY CONCERNS WITH THE
PROPOSAL AT THIS TIME. OKAY
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR BOTH
HEARING NONE OKAY THANK YOU ALL
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR OF.
PRESENTATIONS WE MOVE ON NOW TO
ISSUE FIVE- THIS IS HEPATITIS C.
VIRUS TREATMENT FUNDING
AUGMENTATION AGAIN WE'LL START
WITH CDC ARE. HELLO I AM GREG
DOES STATEWIDE CHEAPER PHARMACY
SERVICE IS OR C. C. H. C. S. C.
C. H. YES IS REQUESTING FUNDING
TO SUPPORT HEPATITIS C. PROGRAM
. THESE RESOURCES WILL BE USED
TO SUPPORT TREATMENT OF ROUGHLY
TWENTY THREE THOUSAND PATIENTS
OVER THE NEXT THREE FISCAL YEARS
. THIS PROPOSAL PROVIDES FUNDING
ON A THREE YEAR LIMITED TERM
BASIS. TO ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT
TO TREAT PATIENTS AND GATHER
DATA ON FUNDING NEEDS TO SUPPORT
PEPSI PROGRAMS ONGOING. I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE ON THIS
PROPOSAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
LOW- FINANCES PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING MADAM SHARED SOME TWENTY
MEMBERS AND FRIENDS- IT
DEPARTMENT FINANCE I NOTICED-
COMMENTS IF THIS TIME- BUT AGAIN
WE'RE AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS
YEAH. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THE
LA OFFICE PLEASE. THANK YOU
AGAIN MY ADAM CHAIR- WE DO NOT
RAISE CONCERNS AT THIS TIME WITH
BUT THE HEPATITIS C. PROPOSAL.
OKAY THANK YOU I DO HAVE A OF A
FEW QUESTIONS AUGUST FOR MISTER
DOLE- WHAT DO YOU BELIEVE SPA
DRIVES THE SPREAD OF H. C. B.
WITHIN THE INCARCERATED.
POPULATION AND ARE THERE OTHER
STEPS AT CDC ARE- SHOULD TAKE TO
REDUCE THAT SPREAD. IT IS AS I
UNDERSTAND IT HI YOU'RE- IT'S
HIGHER ON THE INSIDE INSIDE IT
ON THE OUTSIDE TO GET THAT RIGHT
. NO IT'S THE OPPOSITE. MISTER
DONUT SO THERE'S A NUMBER OF
THINGS THAT WE'VE DONE TO TAKE
CARE OF THE SPREAD WITHIN THAT-
UNFORTUNATELY CO THAT HAS GOTTEN
AWAY ON BEING ABLE TO TREAT
PATIENTS. ARE YOU KNOW PATIENTS
ARE ABLE TO LEARN CLOSE QUARTERS
SO THEY ARE ABLE AFFECT ONE
ANOTHER. AND WE HAVE HAD A
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER PROBLEM.
AT SO WHAT ADDITIONAL STEPS ARE
YOU TAKING ABOUT THAT SPREAD. TO
STOP IT IS WE ARE TREATING
SUBSTANCE YOU KNOW WE ARE
TREATING PATIENTS FOR SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER AND WE ARE RAMPING
BACK UP. ON TREATING OUR
INTERNAL CASES. OKAY COLLEAGUES
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. NO
OKAY ALL RIGHT APPRECIATE THANK
YOU MISTER DOLE AND EVERYONE
APPRECIATE YOUR PRESENTATIONS
WILL MOVE ON TO THE NEXT ISSUE
NUMBER SIX THE INTEGRATED
SUBSTANCE ABUSE SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER TREATMENT PROGRAM
EXPANSION- SOMEONE FROM CDC ARE. THE MORNING WILL BE FINE
CORRECT BURKE LEGISLATION AND
SPECIAL PROJECTS. SERVICE YEAH
AND. I AM THE PROJECT. THE CARD
COULD NOT PREVENT. I WANT TO
THANK THIS BODY PARTS OF I THE
CHIEF PROGRAM. AFFECTS. H.
INSPECTORATE THANK YOU. FOR
SINCE JANUARY ONE WOMAN I YEAH
ALL THIRTY FOUR YOU HAVE
PROVIDED. THIRTY THOUSAND
PROGRAM SPECIALIST. THE OPIATE
CRISIS WITH CARTONS YEAH THANKS
A LOT RIGHT HOW. THANK YOU FOR
THE DEPARTMENT SISTER MARIN.
HAVE INSPECTIONS AND STUFF LIKE
THAT MAKING AVAILABLE OUR
COMPONENTS THANK. AND MEDICARE
ASSISTED TREATMENT PART OF HOW
TO PROVIDING. TRANSACTION
SERVICES CONTINUING TO PROVIDE
OF NOW APPOINTMENT AND WORKING
ARE NONE WE NEED PARTNERS TO
FIND MORE. SUFFERING SEX THE
STOCK FROM. AND STAFF IN HALF
AND QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. IT'S
PROPOSAL AND NOT SEVERAL THE
PROGRAM SUBJECT X. OKAY I. CAN
SOMEONE FROM FINANCE THANK YOU
MISS SIGN. INTERNETOM TERM CRANK
TWENTY TO DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AS HEAR FROM L. A. THERE ARE A
COMMAND THAT SHE SUMMIT A
REVISED FOR CALLS AT THE RIVER.
HOWEVER THE ADMIN NOTES THAT THE
CURRENT. AND IN CAR POPULATION
ARE NOT ANTICIPATE TO IMPEL THE
NEAR EXPANSION OF THIS PROPOSED.
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL A RECENT
REVIEW OF- MEDICATED ASSISTED
TREATMENT PARTICIPANT NUMBERS
INDICATES THAT THE I. S. U. T.
T. PROGRAM REMAINS ON TARGET TO
REACHED A NEARLY EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND MATT PARTICIPANTS BY
JUNE. THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY
TWO AND ROUGHLY TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND PARTICIPANTS BY- JUNE
TWENTY TWENTY THREE THE
ADMINISTRATION RECOGNIZES THAT
THERE IS A POTENTIAL FOR
INCREMENTAL CHANGES IN THE I
GUESS YOU DO YOUR PART TO SOME
POP PARTICIPANT POPULATION FROM
YEAR TO YEAR END ACCORDINGLY-
THIS PROPOSAL ASSUMES THE
SPECIFIC. LEVEL OF POPULATION
DRIVEN RESOURCES FOR THE PROGRAM
WILL BE ADJUSTED EACH YEAR
STARTING IN TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR AS PART OF THE ANNUAL
POPULATION ADJUSTMENT PROCESS
THE. ADMINISTRATION ALSO NOTES
THAT THIS. IT'S AN INVESTMENT
TECH- I ISSUE DEPOT WILL SUPPORT
BETTER. PROVIDE BETTER CRIMINALS
OUTCOMES AND REDUCE THE NEGATIVE
SOCIAL IMPACTS ASSOCIATED WITH
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS. THANK
YOU MR CODY CAN WE HAVE- SOMEONE
FROM- LA- PLEASE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS YEAH MY
NAME'S ORLANDO SANCHEZ BUT THE
L. A. L. WE FIND THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO EXPAND
AND MODIFY THAT NAY GRADED
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER TREATMENT
PROGRAM AS MARRIAGE HOWEVER
BASED ON OUR ASSESSMENT WE HAVE
THREE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WOULD
MODIFY THE PROPOSAL. YOUR FIRST
RECOMMENDING THE LEGISLATURE
DIRECT THE DEPARTMENT OF PROVIDE
A REVISED PROPOSAL AT THE MAY
REVISION. THAT IS ADJUSTED TO
REFLECT THE UPDATED PROJECTIONS
. AS THE OVERALL LEVEL OF
FUNDING BEING REQUESTED CLOSELY
CONNECTED TO THE SIZE OF THE
INMATE POPULATION THE PROPOSAL
WILL LIKELY NEED TO BE ADJUSTED
FOR THE POSSIBILITY. OF THE
INMATE POPULATION MAY BE LOWER
THAN CURRENTLY PROJECTED AS WAS
DISCUSSED IN THE LAST HEARING.
OUR SECOND RECOMMENDATION IS TO
THE EXTENT THE LEISLATURE
CHOOSES TO APPROVE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING. FOR THE INTEGRATED
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER PROGRAM.
WE RECOMMEND THE APPROVAL OF
PROVISIONAL BUDGET LANGUAGE
REQUIRING THAT ANY BUDGET FUNDS
THAT ARE NOT SPENT REVERT BACK
TO THE GENERAL FUND. WE WANT TO
POINT OUT THERE ARE VARIOUS
FACTORS THAT COULD LIMIT THE
DEPARTMENT'S ABILITY TO EXPAND
THE PROGRAM. THESE LIMITATIONS
COULD RESULT IN A DEPARTMENT NOT
USING THE FULL BUDGET AMOUNT.
ONE EXAMPLE OF THIS IS THAT IT
COULD TAKE LONGER TO FILL THE
REQUESTED THREE HUNDRED AND TEN
POSITIONS FOR THE PROGRAM. ALSO
IT IS QUESTIONABLE WHETHER THE
DEPARTMENT WILL HAVE SUFFICIENT
SPACE TO ACCOMMODATE THE LEVEL
NECESSARY FOR THE EXPANSION GIVE
THAT THE DEPARTMENT LAST YEAR
NOTED SUFFICIENT CLASSROOM SPACE
AT THE PRISONS AS A CHALLENGE.
AND LASTLY WE'RE RECOMMENDING
THAT THE LEGISLATURE REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT OF PROVIDE RESULTS OF
THE EVALUATION. FOR THE PROGRAM
SO THAT THE LEGISLATURE CAN
DETERMINE WHETHER I S. U. T. T.
P. IS EFFECTIVELY ACHIEVING ITS
GOALS. OR THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
THE PROGRAM IS NOT YET CLEAR
INITIAL DATA SHOWS THAT
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER RELATED
DOZENS HOSPITALIZATIONS HAVE
DECREASED SINCE THE PROGRAM
BEGAN. AND THE DEPARTMENT
ALREADY INTENDS TO PARTNER WITH
THE UNIVERSITY TO CALIFORNIA TO
VALLEY ASPECTS. FOR WE'RE
RECOMMENDING THE LEGISLATURE-
HAVE THE DEPARTMENT PROVIDE
THESE RESULTS THANK YOU NOT BE
HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU MISTER SANCHEZ- COLLEAGUES
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON
THIS ISSUE. SENATE QUARTERS IN
THE THINK ABOUT YOUR- QUESTION
THE CHEST- IT CERTAINLY. REALLY
TO THE BUDGET I GUESS EVERYTHING
DOES- I DON'T WANT TO ST TWO
FOUR INTO POLICY BUT I'M
CURIOUS- IT FOR SOMEBODY- FOR
THE PRISONERS CAN FROM CBC ARGUS
CAN SPEAK TO- THE OVERDOSE. THE
OVERDOSE DEATHS THAT ARE
OCCURRING- WHAT IS DONE IT TO
ACTUALLY ANALYZE. THIS IS WHAT
WENT DOWN IN THAT PARTICULAR
CIRCUMSTANCE I KNOW THAT YOU
KNOW THERE'S REFERENCES IN THE
MATERIALS HEARING TO THAT RATE
IF YOU WILL PER CAPITA BEING
HIGHER THAN IT IS OUTSIDE- INTO
IN JUST A JUST ONE QUICKLY I
DON'T NEED- A DEEP DIVE INTO
THIS BECAUSE WE COULD ASK FOR
MORE INFORMATION SEPARATELY ON
THIS BUT- I'M JUST. IN TERMS OF
REDUCING INCIDENTS IN TERMS OF.
WHERE DOLLARS ARE GOING HINO TO
INTERVENE IN THIS WHOLE AREA HOW
MUCH IS JUST- PROCURATOR PUT IT
POST MORTEM ANALYSIS ON- WHERE
WHERE THE DRUGS CAME FROM WHAT
THE ACTUAL CONTENT WAS WITHERED-
WHETHER FENTON ALL OR OR OR
OTHER- IT OR OR OR OTHER DRUGS
SAID THAT WE'VE SEEN- IN IN
GROWING NUMBERS. OUTSIDE OF THE
CDC OUR SYSTEM OUR- I
DISABILITIES OVERDOSE DEATHS BUT
AGAIN IF YOU JUST GIVE ME A
THUMBNAIL SKETCH OF WHAT'S DONE
IN TERMS OF THAT KIND OF
ANALYSIS. YES SENATOR I DO
DEFERRED IT AND MY COLLEAGUE DR
RANKING ANSIBLE. GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE- MY NAME IS RENEE
CANINE THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
MEDICAL SERVICES I THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION. ACTUALLY EVERY
DEATH THAT OCCURS IN THE
INCARCERATED. POPULATION HAS
REVIEWED IT- VERY THOROUGHLY BY
. INTERDISCIPLINARY TEAM- IN
TERMS OF- OVERDOSES AS YOU
HEARD- THANK GOODNESS OVERDOSE
DEATHS ARE SIGNIFICANTLY DOWN.
SINCE TWENTY TWENTY AND THEY
CONTINUE TO GO DOWN- PRELIMINARY
DATA SHOWS FOUR ON TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AS WELL- THE REASON FOR
OVERDOSE- WHEN WE HAVE A
SUSPECTED OVERDOSE WE ACTUALLY
AND DO AN AUTOPSY WE ALSO DO
TOXICOLOGY RESULTS AS PART OF
THAT OUR REVIEW AND- REALLY THAT
THE DRUGS. THAT ARE INVOLVED
WITH OVERDOSE DEATHS HAVE NOT
CHANGED IT'S JUST A MUCH LOWER
NUMBER. OF INDIVIDUALS AT THIS
TIME- USUALLY HAIR ONE AND OR
FENNEL ARE INVOLVED WHEN WE ARE
DEALING WITH AN OPIOID. RELATED
OVERDOSE. WE ALSO ACTUALLY HAVE
AN INDEPENDENT. DESK REVIEW DONE
BY DOCTOR OF MINE THAT'S BEEN
GOING ON FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS
AND THAT IS A PUBLIC RECORD. AND
THAT IS POSTED ON OUR WEBSITE.
AND SO IN ADDITION TO OUR OWN-
REVIEWS THAT WE DO ON ALL GAS
AND THERE IS THAT INDEPENDENT
TOWER RECORDS- AGAIN THE REASON
WE DO GET FOR USE IS SO THAT WE
CAN LEARN. FROM EVERY GAS WE
BELIEVE THERE'S ALWAYS
OPPORTUNITIES TO IMPROVE. THE
WAY THAT WE ARE DOING THINGS.
AND OVERDOSE DEATHS. WE USE
THOSE RESULTS TO CONTINUOUSLY
IMPROVE OUR SYSTEM AND THERE ARE
MANY MANY MANY EXAMPLES OF THAT
ARE NOTED IN THE INDEPENDENT
RECORD AS WELL AS OUR OWN
INTERNAL. QUALITY IMPROVEMENT
OUR RECORDS- IN EFFORTS THAT ARE
ONGOING. I MEAN IT TAKES MOTHER
THANK YOU. ID ONE- BELIEVER THE
POINT I APPRECIATE THE OVERVIEW
YOU JUST GAVE AND I. A PROBABLY-
HERE SEPARATELY BETWEEN MEETINGS
ALASKA- A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
IT JUST MORE OF MY OWN CURIOSITY
IN IN IN HOW YOU DISCRIMINATE
YOU KNOW AFTER THOSE- PREVIEWS
BETWEEN- IT MENTAL HEALTH IN
INTENTIONAL. MENTAL HEALTH
RELATED INTENTIONAL SELF
INFLICTION VERSUS- YOU KNOW
SOMEBODY WHOSE WHOSE DRUGS WERE
LACED YOU KNOW IT IT'S SECOND
HAVE PERMISSION I'M INTERESTED
IN AND AGAIN IT'S PROBABLY HAS
MORE TO DO WITH POLICY THAN THIS
BUDGET ITEM HERE TODAY SO AGREE
IT'S GREAT TO HEAR THAT THE
NUMBERS ARE GOING DOWN IN. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WORK IN THAT REGARD
. THANK SENATOR- I HAVE A COUPLE
OF QUESTIONS- SOME POSITIONS
HAVE REACHED OUT TO ME- AND
EXPRESS CONCERN AND DISCOMFORT
WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION OF IN
PARTICULAR OF THE MAT OF
COMPONENT OF WHAT IS CDC ARE
DOING TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIANS ARE
GETTING THE TRAINING AND THE
SUPPORT- AS ESPECIALLY AS OF THE
MAP PROGRAM IS. EXPANDING
FURTHER. YES HELLO THIS IS RENEE
CAN AND AGAIN AND AGAIN THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION. SO YOU
KNOW CHANGE IS ALWAYS
CHALLENGING- AND THIS PROGRAM
REALLY IS TRANSFORMATIONAL FOR
THE DEPARTMENT. AND I AM VERY
HAPPY TO SAY THAT- RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE OVER 98% OF OUR PHYSICIANS-
X. WAVERED WHICH MEANS THAT THEY
CAN PRESCRIBE. AN ORGY AND- MORE
THAN 90% OF OUR PHYSICIAN
WORKFORCE RIGHT WORKFORCE AND
TRANSITION LEADERSHIP HAVE BEEN
TRAINED AS WELL. IN ADDITION TO-
THE EX WAIVER TRAINING THAT'S
AVAILABLE TO EVERYBODY- CSX
WAIVER- WE ALSO HAVE CREATED-
VERY- DETAILED CUSTOMIZED
TRAINING. A SERIES OF TRAININGS-
FOR OUR MEDICAL PROVIDERS STAFF
AND AGAIN THE VAST MAJORITY HAVE
COMPLETED THAT TRAINING. AND IN
FACT THE MAJORITY OF OUR
PHYSICIANS AND OTHER PROVIDERS I
HAVE ACTUALLY- STARTED TO TREAT
THEIR OWN PATIENTS ON THEIR
PANEL- REQUIRE MEDICATION
ASSISTED TREATMENT. SO AT THIS
POINT ALTHOUGH AGAIN CHANGES
IT'S CHALLENGING- WE HAVE
SUPPORTED OUR PROVIDER
WORKFORCE- GAINAX WAIVERS ARE
GETTING TRAINED AND NOW WHAT
WE'RE DOING IS ONGOING-
TECHNICAL SUPPORT CONSULTATION
SUPPORT WE HAVE OFFICE HOURS WE
PROVIDE A TWICE A WEEK- WE HAVE-
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN AVAILABILITY-
IF THERE ARE ANY. COMPLICATIONS
THAT THE BRIGHTER SOME QUESTIONS
ABOUT WE HAVE A CENTRAL TEAM OF
EXPERTS WHO CAN ALSO HELP THEM
MANAGE THAT PATIENT. AND I THINK
WITH ALL THESE EFFORTS- WE ARE
SEEN I'M REALLY QUITE A BIT OF
BUY IN FROM THE PROVIDER
WORKFORCE AT THIS POINT- IN
TERMS OF BEING INVOLVED IN THIS
IMPORTANT PROGRAM THAT SOUND
REALLY SHOWING. PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT- AFFECTED AFFECTED
US. HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS.
WELL I THINK IT'S AN BOB IT MAY
BE AN ONGOING ISSUE SO I REALLY-
OR DO YOU TO KEEP ON WORKING I'M
SURE AS YOU KNOW KEEP ON WORKING
WITH THE POSITIONS ARE SOME OF
THE ISSUES THEY RAISED WERE YOU
KNOW WITH A DISTURBING. TO SAY
THE LEAST AS FAR AS- THERE-
HAVING TO PARTICIPATE WHEN THEY
DIDN'T AGREE WELL WITH. WITH THE
PROGRAM ITSELF OR NOT WITH THE
PROGRAM AS MUCH AS IT WAS ON
INDIVIDUAL CASES SO I JUST URGE
YOU TO KEEP WORKING WITH THE
CONCERNS OF THE OF YOUR
PHYSICIANS. ABSOLUTELY THANK
YOU. MOM AND IF WE COULD HAVE
JUST A REAL REAL QUICK ON THE OF
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA- WHAT INFORMATION
CAN OUR LEGISLATURE HAVE TO-
EXPECT TO GET TO ASSESS THE
PROGRAM. HI YES. HI GOOD MORNING
DENISE ALLEN HERE. WE'VE BEEN
PARTNERING WITH TIME UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA IRVINE TO CONDUCT
PROCESS EVALUATION- AND WE
EXPECT THE RESULTS TO BE READY-
LATER IN THE SPRING OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AND THAT EVALUATION
LOOKS AT INITIAL BCP GOALS AND
APARTMENTS I'M DEPARTMENTS
ABILITY. TO IMPLEMENT THE
PROGRAM AS INTENDED. AND IN THAT
REPORT I BELIEVE THEY WILL
RECOMMEND THAT IN SUMMER TWENTY
TWENTY TWO WE BEGIN TO LOOK AT
PROGRAM OUTCOMES. AND WE EXPECT
DIE IN IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE TO
HAVE SOME PRELIMINARY PROGRAM
OUTCOMES AVAILABLE THROUGH A UC
PARTNERSHIP. SO THE FIRST STEP
IS THE PROCESS EVALUATION WHICH
IS ALREADY UNDER WAY AND THE
SECOND STEP WILL BE TO LOOK AT
PROGRAM OUTCOMES- LATER I
TWENTY TWENTY TO. I AM HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS- MADAM
CHAIR THE MEMBERS MAY HAVE. NO
THAT'S IT FOR ME. MOVEON OKAY
AGAIN THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH.
OF A MISS HINES AND THEN OTHERS
FOR PRESENTING TO OUR COMMITTEE
WE MOVE ON NOW TO ISSUE NUMBER
SEVEN. WHICH IS THE CAL AIM
JUSTICE INVOLVED INITIATIVE-
CDCR. GOOD MORNING I'M TERRIFIED. I STAFF CALIFORNIA IN AN
INNOVATIVE MEDIC OUR OUR
FRAMEWORK THAT ENCOMPASSES THE
FRIDAY ON EVERY SYSTEM IMPROVING
AND HEALTH DISPARITIES AMONG
FRIENDS. MOST VULNERABLE. THE
PARKING EXPRESS I THINK BY TO
IMPLEMENTING THAT WITHIN ABOUT
THE NEXT. BUT JACKSON MOUNTAIN
ALSO COULD BIG THING RIGHT NOW
BOB HERTZBERG NINETY DAYS EVEN
WEEKS SOONER THAN. FIRST TWENTY
ONE THREE. YES I'M SAN. THERE
WILL A RAMP UP THAT THE SEASON
STARTS IN MARCH THAT THEN. S.
THERE WILL BE A. STUDENTS ARE SO
TYPE FROM OPENING UP AGAIN I
REMEMBER THAT ARE NOT KNOWN SB
EIGHT C. R. THANK YOU- I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THEY'RE THERE IS A
PROBLEM WITH THE SOUND. UP WITH
MISS HINES I DON'T KNOW HOW TO
FIX THAT BUT IT IS VERY
DIFFICULT TO THE CATCH
EVERYTHING THAT YOU'RE SAYING
BUT WE'LL MOVE ON- FINANCE DO
YOU WANNA. PRESENT MORE AND
BRING COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES IS CURRENTLY
ENGAGED IN ONGOING CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
REGARDING THE CAL I'M AN
INITIATIVE. AS WELL AS
DISCUSSIONS WILL STAKEHOLDER
GROUPS AT THIS TIME THERE ARE
MANY OPEN CUT QUESTIONS THAT
REMAIN TO BE ANSWERED AND
DETAILS STILL. TO BE WORKED
THROUGH AN ADDITIONAL TIME IS
NEEDED TO DETERMINE MANY OF THE
SPECIFICS OF HOW CALLING WHAT
IMPACT SHOULD BE SHE ARTS
PROGRAMS AND BUDGET. ACCORDINGLY
THE ADMINISTRATION PUT FORWARD
IN THE NATIONAL PROPOSAL THAT
RECOGNIZES THAT CALIFORNIA'S
LIKELY TO CREATE SOME LEVEL OF
ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD FOR CDCR.
RELATED TO ENHANCE COORDINATION
EFFORTS BUT MOST IGNIFICANTLY
THAT CDCR WILL BE ELIGIBLE FOR
IN AN ATTEMPT AN INCREASED LEVEL
OF FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENT FOR
COVERED SERVICES UNDER MEDICAL
WE WOULD LIKE TO UNDERSCORE THAT
THIS IS AN INITIAL PROPOSAL THAT
IS LIKELY TO BE UPDATED WITH
MORE SPECIFICS. YEAH. MORE
INFORMATION AS IT BECOMES
AVAILABLE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OF A ALEJO'S OFFICE PLEASE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR SENATORS
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IS
PROMISING AS IT COULD
POTENTIALLY REDUCE THE STATE
COST OF CDC ARE HOWEVER MANY OF
THE DETAILS OF THE PROPOSAL HAD
NOT YET BEEN DETERMINED.
ACCORDINGLY WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE DIRECT THE
DEPARTMENT TO PROVIDE ANSWERS TO
THE FOLLOWING QUESTIONS SOME OF
THESE QUESTIONS INCLUDE. WHAT
WILL THE VERAGE FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENT RATE BE FOR THE
TRANSITION PLANNING SERVICES
WHAT SPECIFIC YOU'LL TRANSITION
PLANNING ACTIVITIES WILL TAKE
PLACE. WHAT SPECIFIC TRANSITION
PLANNING ACTIVITIES AT CDC ARE
ALREADY ENGAGES AND WILL BECOME
FEDERALLY REIMBURSABLE AND
WHETHER THESE POTENTIAL SAVINGS
ARE BEING ACCOUNTED FOR IN THE
PROPOSAL. ADDITIONALLY UNDER
THAT NEW TRANSITION PLANNING
PROCESSES. WELL INMATES RELEASED
A STATE PAROLE CONTINUAL TO BE
REFERRED A CDCR FUNDED MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER TREATMENT SERVICE
PROVIDERS IN THE COMMUNITY. THE
FULL LIST OF QUESTIONS CAN B
FOUND IN THE AGENDA BUT THESE
ARE SOME THAT THE LEGISLATURE
MIGHT WANT TO CONSIDER DIRECTING
TO THE DEPARTMENT. THANK YOU AND
HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS. THANK
TO ASSIGN TWO IS- COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. YES
SENATE QUARTERS IN. WHAT IS WHAT
IS THE ORDERS OR EXPERIENCE
WITH- WITH INCARCERATED PERSONS
HAVING THEIR THERE ARE. PRE
RELEASE PLAN IN PLACE BEFORE
THEY WERE ACTUALLY RELEASED IS
IT. IS IT CLOSE TO A 100% THERE
SIR DO WE KNOW WHAT THE
PERCENTAGES- IN. I'M WONDERING.
IF THE US IS ALWAYS DONE SO THAT
LOCAL REENTRY CENTERS. ASSEMBLY
RECEIVE THAT PROPERLY. IN A WITH
A PLAN IN PLACE OR ARE WE
RELYING ON ON LOCALS TO DO THAT.
BUT FOR SOME OF THE CASES.
BERMAN WHO. IT'S VERY- MUFFLED
YEAH IT'S VERY ROUGH- DO YOUR
BEST TO MAYBE TALK JUST A LITTLE
BIT SLOWER MAYBE COULD CATCH
MORE OF WHAT YOU'RE SAYING. AND
SO MANY DIFFERENT BRANDS. HARPER. NINE SEVEN SEVEN. SACRAMENTO
WELL AS OUR HELLO MY FEELINGS
ARE REMAINS WHERE. I CAN'T PLAN
AS- IDENTIFIED SO YEAH ZETA
BIRTH ALL THE BENEFITS. GENERAL
RULES HERE YEAH FOR HAVE.
MORNING AFTER FINANCING. YEAH
THAT. IT'S FRANK ACCESS- THE ONE
HAND THAT FOR THOSE THAT ARE
HIGH. HI RISK MEDICAL. YES YES
L. BRANDS WHICH AND WITHOUT HAND
ARE. COOL FOR TIME ME SO IN YOUR
- PERFECT WORLD SO TO SPEAK
WINDOWS THE WINDOWS THE INMATE
STILL I'M ASSUMING STILL
INCARCERATED- WHEN WOULD YOU
LIKE THEM TO BE FAMILIAR WITH.
EVERYTHING THAT PLAN THAT'S
GOING TO BE TAKING PLACE AND
TURNS THE ALARM OFF IS IT A WEEK
BEFORE OR IS IT A MONTH BEFORE
VISIT. YOU NOTICING THAT. SOME
MAY HAVE WANTED TO PARTICIPATE
IN SOME QUEUE IN A AS TO HOW
THINGS ARE GOING TO LOOK FOR
THEM. THE CURRENT PROCESS
STARTED MEETING DATES PRIOR TO
REMAIN. AT THE REAL IMPACT OF
WHAT IT WOULD NOW- CURRENT WAR
AGAINST TERRORISM. THANK. I AM
NOT SHOWING THAT IT'S AN
ACCOUNTING AND NOT IN THIS. YEAH
AND SEVEN SEVEN NINE DATE
INTERESTS THERE WERE A LOT TO
PROVIDE AND ENHANCE WIPES SHE
GOT HIRED. SITTING CHAIN
MORTGAGE OR A MEDIC OUR MEDICAL
APATHY. ARE. ALL OF LAST NIGHT'S. INFORMATION ALLOWED TO BE
TRANSFERRED OVER- I MEAN I'M
AWARE OF. ALL KINDS OF
CONFIDENTIALITY STATUTES AROUND
THAT KIND OF INFORMATION I'M
JUST WONDERING IF THAT CAN BE
DONE WITHOUT A WAIVER FROM. FROM
THE INMATE. SO RIGHT NOW
DEPENDING ON THE INFORMATION AND
THERE'S A PLANNING PROCESS SO
ANYONE THAT'S PART OF THAT WHEN
I SENT. IT'S ALLOWED HEALTH THE
FACT AND ARE WE ARE LOOKING AT
WORKING WITH THE FIRM OUR
SERVICE. THANK YEAH. YOU.
TRANSACTION I MEAN FOR ME THAT
SOMETHING THAT FOR A LOT OF
PEOPLE WORKING ON TO TRY TO THAT
. TO TRAIN SERVICES HAVING SAID
THAT WE DO GRANT SOME OF.
INFORMATION TO THAT MOVIE AND
ALLOW. YEAH WITH IT WOULD BE YOU
FOR A TO KNOW. FOR POLICY
PURPOSE OF. IF LEGISLATION- MY
REQUIRED OF THE C. WOULD BE
DECISION WHETHER TO A AT RISK.
IN ORDER TO ROUTE. ADDITIONAL BE
HOLD HIM FOR IN A- OF A- IN NOT
ONLY TO MAKE THE PART OF THE
PLAY- THE YOU'RE PUTTING YOUR A
CD ARE SO BUT TO MAKE SURE IT'S
FOR- I THINK. I THINK. WHAT'S
MORE THAN ANECDOTAL BUT I THINK
SO MUCH OF WHAT WE SEE IN TERMS
OF SITUATIONS THAT DON'T GO
RIGHT. OR THEY GO HORRIBLY
WRONG- HILL INVOLVING RECIDIVISM
OR INVOLVING YOU KNOW SOME. SOME
FORM OF VIOLENCE OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT SEEMS TO TIE BACK TO.
IN ANOTHER LINE MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITION THAT PEOPLE JUST
WEREN'T READY TO. WELCOME TO PUT
THE PROPER WRAPAROUND SERVICES
IN PLACE OR TO A PAID EXTRA
ATTENTION TO WITH THAT IN ME
WHEN THEY GET TO THE COUNTY
LEVEL SO- THAT'S THE- MOTIVATION
FOR MY QUESTION I JUST WANNA- I
WANT TO KNOW IF THERE'S
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO DO
STATUTORILY TO- TO STREAMLINE
THAT PROCESS AND IN TO TAKE SOME
OF THE OBSTACLES OUT OF WHAT
INFORMATION YOU CAN PUSH DOWN
THE COULD THE COUNTIES I MEAN
OBVIOUSLY BECOMES OR
SUBDIVISIONS OF THE STATE
ANYWAY. IT WOULD SEEM TO ME
THAT- THE PRACTICE SHOULD BE-
HERE AT LEAST WITHIN THE TWO
ENTITIES- NO A FREEFORM KIND OF
SHARING OF THE KIND OF
INFORMATION BUT- THOSE ARE MY
OPINIONS. IN A PREDICAMENT TO
THE QUESTIONS OF THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR THERE NEWMAN.
OKAY OKAY GREAT- I JUST TERM I
KNOW MR CODY MENTIONED THAT
THERE'S STILL A LOT TO A LOT
MORE DETAIL TO BE PUT ON THIS
EXPECT TO DO THAT FOR THE WITH
THE MAY REVISE- MAYBE I'LL JUST
ADD TO THE SOME O THE QUESTIONS
THAT THE L. A. L. ASKED-
PRESENTED ON SOME OF THEM IF YOU
CAN ANSWER NOW THAT WOULD BE
GREAT OTHERWISE- I THINK THAT
THE KINDS OF QUESTIONS THAT WE
EXPECT AND NEED TO BE ANSWERED-
IF. HOW WILL THIS INITIATIVE BE
ALIGNED WITH- THE EXISTING PRE
AND POST RELEASE PROGRAMS OF-
AND WHAT NEW PRESS A PRE RELEASE
ACTIVITIES NOT ALREADY UP
PERFORMED BY CDCR WILL BE PART
OF THIS INITIATIVE AND OUT WHAT
ARE THE KEY BARRIERS AND
CONNECTING PATIENTS TO SERVICES
UPON THEIR RELEASE AND HOW WILL
THIS INITIATIVE ADDRESS THOSE.
IF YOU WANT TO ANSWER NOW OR IF
YOU'RE SAYING. YOU'LL DO IT. IN
THE PROCESS OF THE BUDGET. I
THINK WILL WORK WITH OUR HEALTH
CARE SERVICES AND COLLEAGUES
FOUND THAT AND FROM THE FINANCE
AND SELF PARKING FINANCING RIGHT
NOW. THAT WAS COOL. THIS IS
ALICE IN HUMAN FROM THE OF
FINANCE IF I CAN JUST ADD IT TO
MY COLLEAGUES COMMENTS. I'M MORE
HAPPY ABSOLUTELY HAPPY TO FOLLOW
UP WITH THE CHAIR AND MEMBERS ON
THE QUESTIONS THAT ARE BEING
PUBLISHED I THINK THOUGH EVEN IF
THE ALEJO WOULD LIKELY CONCEDE
THAT THERE'S- SOME OF THAT
INFORMATION IS JUST NOT GOING TO
BE AVAILABLE AT THE MOMENT. AND
I THINK THAT'S BECAUSE AS MY
COLLEAGUE I BRING CODY
MENTIONED. THE EIGHT BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES IS ACTIVELY WORKING
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN
ORDER TO DETERMINE SOME OF THE
KEY COMPONENTS OF THE CALLINAN
IT SHOULD HAVE. SO UNLIKE MANY
OF THE PROPOSALS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION BRINGS BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE IN THIS CASE WERE
LACKING SOME OF THOSE KEY
DETAILS AND IT'S JUST AN ISSUE
THAT REALLY RELATES TO THE POINT
IN TIME AND I JUST WANT TO
REITERATE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
COMMITMENT TO SHARING
INFORMATION WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AS IT BECOMES AVAILABLE. BUT
RIGHT NOW I DON'T NOW THAT WERE
ABLE TO SPEAK TO ALL OF THESE
THINGS AND IT'S NOT BECAUSE YOU
SEE OUR IS IT DOING INCREDIBLE
DUE DILIGENCE IT'S JUST BECAUSE
WE'RE IN A TIMING ISSUE WHERE.
THIS INITIATIVE ISN'T
NECESSARILY LINING UP WITH THE
BUDGET PROCESS BUT WE WILL
ABSOLUTELY RESPOND TO ALL OF
THESE QUESTIONS AS WERE ABLE TO
BUT YOU MIGHT SEE SOME UNKNOWNS
AT THIS TIME BECAUSE WE'RE JUST
NOT ABLE TO SPEAK TO THAT AND
ARE PROPOSAL RECOGNIZES THAT BUT
WE ARE COMMITTED. TO SHARING
INFORMATION WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE L. A. L. AS WE WORK
THROUGH THIS AND SOME OF THE-
COVERAGE SERVICES AND OTHER
DETAILS THAT ARE STILL.
OUTSTANDING- ARE DETERMINES.
THANK YOU MISS YOU IT GUESS- THE
- ISSUE OF FEDERAL WE- TODAY
OBVIOUSLY A- IS A- HAS A BIG
IMPACT ON THESE PROPOSALS SO.
LOOK FORWARD TO THAT FURTHER
INFORMATION THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
WE MOVE ON NOW TO- ISSUE EIGHT
WITCHES ARE RETURNING HOME
WHILE. FROM CDC ARE PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SIGN IN YOU
CAN SEE IS DEPUTY DIRECTOR WITH
THE DIVISION OF REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS. CDCR IS REQUESTING
FUNDING TO SUPPORT THE RETURNING
HOME WHILE PROGRAM. IS RESOURCES
WILL BE USED TO SUPPORT
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING SERVICES TO
APPROXIMATELY ELEVEN HUNDRED
TROLLEYS. WE ESTIMATE WILL BE
IDENTIFIED AS HOMELESS OR
HOUSING INSECURE UPON RELEASE.
THE DEPARTMENT RECEIVED ONE TIME
FUNDING TO SUPPORT EMERGENCY
HOUSING IN RESPONSE TO THE COULD
MAKE TÍNH PANDEMIC WHICH
HIGHLIGHTED THE NEED FOR ONGOING
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING RESOURCES.
PROVIDING ROWLEY IS A SAFE PLACE
TO TRANSITION BACK INTO THE
COMMUNITY HAS A POSITIVE EFFECT
ON THE REINTEGRATION. THIS
PROPOSAL PROVIDES FUNDING ON A
THREE YEAR LIMITED TERM BASIS.
TO ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT TO
GATHER DATA ON HOUSING NEEDS OF
THE RELEASING POPULATION AND
OVERALL PROGRAM PARTICIPATION TO
SUPPORT THE PROGRAM ONGOING I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE ON THIS
PROPOSAL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISS CÁC AS OUR FINANCE PLEASE.
BROWN'S OIL PARTNER FINANCE
NOTICE ALL COMMENTS TO ADD AT
THIS TIME BUT I HAVE TO ANSWER
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS SHOULD YOU
HAVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- LL'S OFFICE PLEASE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND CENTERS AT
THIS TIME WE'RE NOT RAISING
CONCERNS WITH THE PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU OF. THE JUST HAVE A
COUPLE QUESTIONS FOR CDC ARE-
WHAT STEPS CAN YOU TAKE- TO HELP
PEOPLE SECURE MORE PERMANENT
HOUSING- PRE RELEASE. TO REDUCE
THE NEED FOR EMERGENCY HOUSING.
AND- ARE THERE ENOUGH PLACEMENTS
FOR THE ANTICIPATED HOUSING NEED
- IF YOU COULD ANSWER THOSE
APPRECIATED THANK YOU. OF COURSE
THANKS FOR THAT QUESTION- AS FAR
AS WHAT WE CAN DO FOR THE
HOUSING NEED- ONE OF THE THINGS
WE WILL CONTINUE TO DO IT IS
CONTINUE TO USE OUR- OTHER ENTRY
OPTIONS WITH THE MALE COMMUNITY
REENTRY PROGRAMS AND THE
COMMUNITY- ARTISTIC COMMUNITY
TRANSITION PROGRAMS. WHICH ALLOW
US TO HELP- OUR RESIDENTS
TRANSITION BACK HOUSING BEFORE
THEY RELEASED- AND AS FAR AS
FINDING HOUSING FOR THEM IF THEY
END UP IN THIS PROGRAM RETURNING
HOME. OUR PARTNERS- I'M IN THE
STOCK PROGRAMS WORK WITH LOCAL.
SERVICES TO GET THEM PERMANENT
HOUSING. ON A PERMANENT. AND I
YOUR NEXT QUESTION. WAS DO WE
HAVE ENOUGH BASIS FOR WHAT WE DO
HAVE NUMEROUS BEDS IN OUR STOCK
PROGRAM CURRENTLY WE ONLY HAVE
FUNDING FOR A PORTION OF THOSE
BEDS- AND THIS WILL ADDED TO THE
ADDITIONAL BEDS THAT WE CAN USE
SO. WE EXPECT THAT WE WILL BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT. THE NEED. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- COLLEAGUES
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. NO
HEARING NONE OKAY WELL AGAIN
THANK YOU MISTER CIESZYN AND
OTHERS FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND
PRESENTATION THE MOVE ON NOW TO.
ISSUE- NINE THE CALIFORNIA
PRISON INDUSTRY AUTHORITY
JANITORIAL EXPANSION CDCR PLEASE
. HELLO DAN LEWIS W. DIRECTOR OF
FACILITIES PLANNING APPLICATION
MANAGEMENT CCHS IS REQUESTING
FUNDING TO SUPPORT THE
JANITORIAL SERVICES CONTRACT
WITH LPA THIS CONTRACT PROVIDES
FOR THE HEALTHCARE FACILITIES
MAINTENANCE PROGRAM WHICH IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR CLEANING AND
SANITIZING. IN CARE AREAS IN
INSTRUCTION HEALTH CARE
LOCATIONS THESE RESOURCES WILL
SUPPORT NECESSARY STAFFING
LEVELS AND RECOGNIZE THE
ADDITIONAL SERVICE LOCATIONS
NAMELY THE PSYCHIATRIC INPATIENT
PROGRAM. SALINAS VALLEY STATE
PRISON. STANDALONE DENTAL
CLINICS AND NEWLY CONSTRUCTED
MEDICAL SPACE HFM PROGRAM
OFFENDERS PROPOSED INCARCERATION
EMPLOYMENT THROUGH A CERTIFIED
HEALTHCARE ENVIRONMENTAL
SERVICES PROFESSIONAL PROGRAM
ADMINISTERED BY CAL PA STAFF.
WITH THE AMERICAN HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION AND I AM HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
YOU HAVE ON THIS PROPOSAL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER LEWIS OF
FINANCE PLEASE. I SIMPLY MENDOZA
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE SUPPORT
THE EXPANSION OF CLEANING
SERVICES AND WANT TO NOTE THAT
THE CUSTODIAN SUPERVISORY RATIOS
RANGE- ACROSS INSTITUTIONS AN
AVERAGE ABOUT FORTY INCARCERATED
IN CIVIL SERVICE CUSTODIAN
STOPPED TWO ONE CIVIL SERVICES
CUSTODIAN SUPERVISOR. IT
PROVIDES RE POSITIONS ARE ABOUT
OVERSIGHT STAFF DEVELOPMENT AND
TRAINING. LPI IS GOALS ARE
TRUTHFUL WELL THERE IS NO DOUBT
HELPED GUYS GOAL IS TO PROVIDE A
QUALITY JANITORIAL SERVICES AND
THEY'RE DOING SO THEIR MISSION
IS TO ENHANCE PUBLIC SAFETY BY
PROVIDING INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS PRODUCTIVE WORK AND
TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES TO
IMPROVE THEIR PLAYABILITY
POSTING COURSE RATIONS.
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
SUPERVISORS WOULD ALLOW CALPE
ITEM GROUP THE QUALITY- THAT
CALCULATE PROVIDES. AND CLEANING
SERVICES TO BETTER MEET THEIR
MISSION BY PROVIDING MORE
FEEDBACK ON THE JOB TRAINING
CONTROL AND OVERSIGHT OF
INVENTORY AND PROCESS THESE. AS
WELL AS FINDING AND KEEPING
QUALIFIED STAFF. THIS PROPOSAL
WOULD CHANGE THAT RATIO FROM
FORTY TO ONE TO ABOUT TWENTY TWO
ONE- AND WOULD ALLOW CALCULATED
BY THAT EXPECTED SUPERVISION
THAT'S NEEDED THANKS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH L. WAS OFTEN PLEASE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR SENATORS
WE VIEW THIS PROPOSAL AS HAVING
TWO COMPONENTS. THE FIRST IS
THAT IT EXPANDS THE CONTRACT
CONTINUE HEALTH CARE FACILITIES
THE SECOND IS THAT HE PROPOSES
TO CHANGE THE RATIO OF CUSTODIAN
SUPERVISORS TAKE A STUDY AND
STAFF AND WE ASSESS THE PROPOSAL
IN THESE TWO COMPONENTS. GIVEN
THE QUALITY OF THE SERVICES
PROVIDED BY CAL PA THAT THEY
HAPPEN NEXT AT AN ACCEPTABLE
STANDARD AND NOT RAISED MAJOR
CONCERNS WE FIND THE PROPOSAL TO
EXPAND THE CONTRACTS INCLUDE
ADDITIONAL HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES REASONABLE. WELL WE
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
IMPROVE THE FUNDING NECESSARY TO
EXPAND INTO NEW HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES THIS REGARD. HOWEVER
THE SECOND PART OF THE PROPOSAL
TO CHANGE THE RATIO OF CUSTODIAN
SUPERVISORS TAKE A STARTING.
APPEARS ANALYSIS. THEREFORE WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE REJECT
THE FUNDING NECESSARY CHANGE THE
RATIO OF CUSTODIAN SUPERVISORS
TAKE A STARTING STAFF. IN THEIR
PROPOSAL CAL PA RAISES PROBLEMS
RESULTING FROM LACK OF REACH
SUPERVISORS SUCH ISSUES
INCLUDING NOT PROPERLY KEEPING
INVENTORY NOT PROVIDING TIMELY
EVALUATIONS TO CUSTODIANS AND A
FEW OTHERS WE KNOW THAT THESE
PROBLEMS. REYES HAVE NOT HAD A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON THE
QUALITY OF SERVICE PROVIDED WELL
WE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE PROBLEMS
RAISED BY COUNTY A COULD IMPACT
THE PROGRAM IN OTHER WAYS IT IS
NOT CLEAR HOW THESE. ADDITIONAL
SUPERVISORS PROPOSED WHAT IN
FACT ALLEVIATE THOSE PROBLEMS
FOR EXAMPLE IT'S POSSIBLE THAT
OTHER ACTIONS SUCH AS ADDITIONAL
TRAINING WOULD ADDRESS THOSE-IDENTIFIED PROBLEMS IN A MORE
EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT MANNER.
SO WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ONLY IMPROVE THE
FUNDING NECESSARY TO EXPAND INTO
HEALTH CARE FACILITIES. AND
DIRECT CAL PA TO REPORT THE
AMOUNT REQUESTED ASSOCIATED WITH
CHANGING THE RACIAL OF
SUPERVISORS SEPARATELY WE NOTE
THAT AT THE TIME OF OUR ANALYSIS
. I CALCULATE WASN'T ABLE TO
PROVIDE THIS SEPARATE A
SEPARATION BETWEEN THE TWO- BUT
BASED ON LIMITED DATA WE
ESTIMATE THAT. THE RATIO IS
ASSOCIATED WITH SEVERAL MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS OF CHANGING THE
SUPERVISOR TO STAFF RATIO THANK
AND I'D BE HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU- MISTER
LEWIS COULD YOU RESPOND TO THE
L. A. O.'S- ISSUES ON THE SECOND
PROPOSAL. WELL YES- WHILE I
AGREE WITH US THAT THEY CAN OKAY
PROGRAM HAS PROVIDED ADEQUATE
SERVICES TO THIS POINT. THERE IS
CONCERNS RELATED TO ABILITY TO
PROVIDE THE OVERSIGHT AND
TRAINING OF THE FENDERS- WITH
THE STAFF THAT THEY HAVE
AVAILABLE- YOU KNOW DELEO SAYS
THAT ADDITIONAL TRAINING. BUT I
WOULD REQUIRE ADDITIONAL STAFF
TO PROVIDE THAT ADDITIONAL
TRAINING THAT THEY RECOMMEND- I
THINK STOPS AND GIVEN THAT THIS
PROGRAM IS MEANT TO PREPARE
OFFENDERS FOR JOBS ON THE
OUTSIDE I'M THINGS THAT WE CAN
DO TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
MENTORING AND TRAINING TO THE
STAFF TO THOSE INMATES STAFF
WOULD REALLY HELP THE PROGRAM
MEET ITS OBJECTIVES IN
PROVIDING. AND THE SKILLS TO
THOSE OFFENDERS I'M
ADDITIONALLY- TELL YOUR CRACK
THAT THERE IS SEVERAL DOLLAR
RELATED TO. THESE ADDITIONAL
SUPERVISORY POSITIONS ABOUT
THREE POINT SIX MILLION IN THE
FIRST YEAR AND AN ADDITIONAL ONE
POINT NINE AND SECOND YEAR- THAT
IS THE AMOUNT RELATED TO THE
INCREASED. RATIO OF SUPERVISION-
BUT WE DO FEEL THAT THOSE THOSE.
I AM. REQUESTS ARE ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPORTANT TO THE
PROGRAM OVERALL TO MEET ITS
OBJECTIVES. CORRECT ARM THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER LEWIS- I
HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS ARE
THE INCARCERATED PERSONS WHO
WORK IN THESE JOBS. ABLE TO BE
HIRED ON AS A CIVIL SERVICE
CUSTODIANS POST RELEASE- I KNOW
IT IT IT IT FROM WHAT YOU ALL
SAY THAT THE- YOU KNOW. PART OF
THE MISSION OF A PROGRAM LIKE
THIS IS TO ENHANCE THEIR
OPPORTUNITIES- TO BE ABLE TO GET
A WORK WHEN THEY ARE RELEASED
SO. HOW ARE THEY SUPPORTED IN
THEIR ATTEMPTS TO FIND WORK POST
RELEASE- WHETHER IT'S CIVIL
SERVICE OR PRIVATE POSITIONS AND
YOU KNOW HOW DOES HOW DO YOU HOW
ARE YOU HELPING THEM. HOW AND
HOW SUCCESSFUL IS THE PROGRAM IN
HELPING THEM. GET TO THEIR GOALS
OF BEING ABLE TO HAVE A JOB ON
THAT'S IN THERE AFTER THEY'RE
RELEASED- I DON'T HAVE THE
SPECIFIC ANSWERS I'LL BE HAPPY
TO GET SOME INFORMATION FROM CAL
PA. ASSOCIATED WITH- WITH THOSE
THOSE QUESTIONS AND SUCCESS ON
PLACING OFFENDERS- IN GENERAL WE
DON'T HAVE- A LOT OF JANITORIAL
POSITIONS AND CDCR. THAT WOULD
BE CIVIL SERVICE AND CAN WITH
THEIR STATUS AS A AS A FELON DAY
WOULD GENERALLY BE DISQUALIFIED
FROM WORKING IN PRISONS WITHOUT
WITHOUT IT. OUT SOME SORT OF
EXCEPTION- BUT I CAN GET ANSWERS
TO YOUR QUESTIONS FROM CAL PA AS
FAR AS THE SUCCESS IN PLACING
OFFENDERS AND ANY- EFFORTS THEY
MAKE IN TRYING TO GET OFFENDERS
JOBS. ON ONCE THEY'VE BEEN
RELEASED. OKAY I MEAN I'LL BE.
YOU YOU KNOW WE RUN ACROSS THIS
ISSUE IN A LOT OF DIFFERENT.
INDUSTRIES SECTORS OF THE
ECONOMY IS HOW DO WE HELP THE
FORMERLY INCARCERATED GET A JOB
AND SEE THEMSELVES AS HAVING A
CAREER. A JOB. THAT PAYS WELL TO
SUPPORT THEMSELVES SO THAT THEY
DON'T END UP BACK IN PRISON SO-
I WOULD REALLY URGE ONE IS TO
GIVE US THE INFORMATION. AND YOU
MIGHT EVEN HAVE SOME SUGGESTIONS
ON HOW TO GO ABOUT. INCREASING
THEIR UP CHANCES OF GETTING A
JOB POST RELEASE VERSUS YOU KNOW
JUST. HAVING GOTTEN THE TRAINING
AND THEN WHERE DO THEY END UP
WITH THAT HOW WHAT GOOD DOES IT
DO THEM IN IN THE WORLD- AFTER
THEY'RE RELEASED. K. THANK IN
ADVANCE I DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
I JUST WANT TO KNOW AND WHILE I
DON'T HAVE AN ANSWER TO YOUR
QUESTION IN THAT RESPECT. THIS
IS A SPECIALIZED- TRAINING THAT
THEY GET AND THE HEALTHCARE
CLEANING IS SPECIALIZED AND THEY
DO RECEIVE- CERTIFICATIONS-
ACROSS VARIOUS CATEGORIES THAT
ALLOW THEM- AND A GREATER
EMPLOYABILITY ONCE THEY'RE OUT.
I JUST WANTED TO KNOW THAT
THANKS. YES SIR NEWMAN AGENCIES
IS THEIR DATA AVAILABLE ON THE
POST INCARCERATION POINT.
SUCCESS IN MAY TO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS PROGRAM AND IF THERE IS NOT
SUGGEST THAT WE SHOULD FIGURE
OUT. SOME DECENT BASIS FOR
COLLECTING IT ESPECIALLY THE
EXTENT THAT YOU'RE ASKING FOR
ADDITIONAL MONEY THAT MONEY IS
SURELY JUSTIFIED IF THERE'S IF
THERE'S A POSITIVE IMPACT ON
POST INCARCERATION PLAN SCHOOL
HARD TO JUST FIVE FOR MY COLLEGE
NIGHT IF THERE IS NOT. MR LEWIS
OR BUDGET WILL REACH OUT TO CAL
PA TO GET ANY INFORMATION THEY
HAVE REGARDING POST
INCARCERATION IMPLEMENTS- I
DON'T HAVE THAT DATA IN FRONT OF
ME BUT I WILL GET THAT
INFORMATION FOR YOU GREAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH YES SIR CORTEZ.
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE MY
COLLEAGUES QUESTIONS. EXCELLENT
I THINK THIS AREA. IT IS AGAIN
DESPITE THE FACT WERE FOCUS IN A
VERY PARTICULAR VERY SPECIFIC
BUDGET ITEMS YOU KNOW HAS A
TENDENCY TO RAISE MORE QUESTIONS
THAN- WE'RE PROBABLY GETTING THE
ANSWER FOR RIGHT NOW- BY THE- I
JUST WANT TO MAKE A COMMENT IN
A- IN A IN A SERIOUS COMMENT I
DON'T MEAN IT TO BE- IN ANYWAY-
HUH. THIS RESPECTFUL AT ALL PUT
. OR I'M CONCERNED IF SOMEBODY'S
QUALIFIED AS AN INMATE TO DO
WORK- BASED ON RISK BASED ON
TRAINING BASED ON GENERAL
QUALIFICATIONS. AND THE ONLY
THING THAT WOULD STOP THEM FROM
QUALIFYING FOR THE JOB POST
RELEASE IS PHONY THAT'S ON THE
RECORD I THINK WE HAVE A
PROBLEM- I'M A PUBLIC POLICY
STANDPOINT WE'RE EITHER. WE HAVE
A SYSTEM PRISON SYSTEM THAT'S
PREPARING PEOPLE REHABILITATING
THEM OR OR WE DON'T AND- I
TOTALLY UNDERSTAND- IF THERE'S
HIGH RISK- INMATES WERE HIGH
RISK FELONS THAT THAT WOULDN'T
BE. THAT WOULD BE PRESENTED
WOULD NOT BE PRESENTED WITH THAT
OPPORTUNITY YOU KNOW INSIDE OR
OR ELSE- BUT IF. A LITTLE BIT
UNFAIR TO TELL SOMEONE. YOUR
WORK IS JUST FINE FOR THIRTY
FIVE CENTS AN HOUR ASSEMBLY
IMPRISONED BUT- DON'T BOTHER
APPLYING- FOR THE SAME JOB- HERO
AS AS AS A FREE MEMBER OF
SOCIETY- PETER JUST SEEMS
PROBLEMATIC COMMITTEE POLICY WAS
PUBLIC POLICY WAS. A JUST- I DO
HAVE A QUESTION OR TWO IT IS HAS
THE RIGHT THIS RATE. FOR THEIR
WORK- IN AN EIGHT HUNDRED TEN
WE'RE TALKING A VERY SPECIFIC
CLASS OF A JOB TRAINING HERE.
BUT HAS HAS THE RATE BEEN.
EVALUATED RECENTLY. WHEN WAS IT
ESTABLISHED AND HOW OFTEN IS IT
REVISITED THREE TO PAY HIM
TALKING ABOUT. IT HASN'T BEEN
REEVALUATED RECENTLY THAT I'M
AWARE OF- WE CAN CERTAINLY TAKE
A LOOK AT THAT- BUT THE RATES
HAVE BEEN GENERALLY THE SAME FOR
SOMETIME. YEAH A IT I'D BE
INTERESTED IN SEEN CDC ARE
REEVALUATED BUT IN THE BROADER
CONTEXT OF WHAT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT FOR MOST OF THE
MORNING HERE IN TERMS OF
PREPARATION FOR RELEASE- IN ON
THE- WE HAVE ALL KINDS OF
PROGRAMS OUTSIDE CAL SAVORING
AND- EVERYTHING YOU CAN IMAGINE
PENSIONS FOR ONE CASE IT SAID-
THAT. ONE LOVE ONE ANOTHER
ASSIST WORKERS WITH THE CENTURY
PUTTING MONEY ASIDE- IT SEEMS TO
ME THAT- IN COMBINATION WITH THE
VALUE EIGHTEEN THIS- THIS RATE
PER HOUR. THAT WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING AT A SYSTEM THAT SETS UP
A TRUST. A SAVINGS TRUST FOR
THOSE INMATES SO THAT IF THE
GOAL IS THAT THEY BE GAINFULLY
EMPLOYED WHEN THEY GET OUT. CAN
I GET GIVEN EVERYTHING THAT WE
KNOWN WHAT WE'VE HEARD TODAY IN
TERMS OF THE NEED TO PROVIDE
HOUSING. AND WRAPAROUND SERVICES
AND OTHER SUPPORT I THINK MOST
OF US KNOWING MOST OF US HAVE
COME FROM COUNTIES WITH RE ENTRY
CENTERS KNOW THAT ON THE BIGGEST
PROBLEMS THAT WE HAVE LOCALLY.
UPON RELEASE IS THAT- THE WELL
INTO MA HAS ABSOLUTELY NO CASH
HAND- TO GET STABILIZED IN A
PLACE LIKE SAN FRANCISCO OR LOS
ANGELES OR SILICON VALLEY- SO.
HE'LL CLEARLY SOMEONE WILL HAVE
TO GIVE SOME THOUGHT TO HOW YOU
. DO THAT WITH. A SOME KIND OF A
CONSTRUCTIVE. WORK CONSTRUCTED
TRUST A REAL TRUST THAT WOULD BE
PASSED OVER TO COUNTY OFFICIALS
TO HELP HI YOU KNOW DISTRIBUTE
STIPENDS OUT OF A TOTAL THOSE
SAVINGS AND AGAIN I UNDERSTAND.
THIS IS ELISE IN THIS PARTICULAR
ITEM THIS IS A SMALL WORLD THREE
SMALL NUMBER OF FOLKS BUT- MAYBE
A GREAT. OPPORTUNITY TO DO
SOMETHING ORE- SO. WHATEVER
IT'S WORTH NOTING THAT
DISCUSSION OR YOU KNOW I'M HAPPY
TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS SO AFTER
TODAY ABOUT WHAT WOULD BE
REQUIRED IF ANYTHING FROM THE
LEGISLATURE TO HELP SET YOU KNOW
SAID THAT KIND OF DIRECTION OF.
THANK YOU MANAGER GREAT THANK
YOU SEND A COURTESY I THINK
THESE ARE ALL- REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS AS WE INVEST
AS A STATE WE INVEST BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS INTO PROGRAMS. POST
RELEASE ACROSS THE STATE- AND
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
COORDINATION OF PRE RELEASE
SERVICES AND POST RELEASE
SERVICES BUT THE FUNDAMENTAL
ISSUE FOR ANYONE LEAVING PRISON
IS WHAT'S MY FUTURE. FOUR HOW DO
I GET TO A BETTER PLACE AND OF A
CRITICAL PART OF THAT OF COURSE
IS A JOB IN A CAREER SO- WE'RE
SORT OF IF WE DON'T INVEST ON
THAT END OF IT THEN WE'RE
MISSING THE BOAT AND ONLY
INVESTING ON THE SERVICES SIDE
OF IT SO- I'D- REALLY
APPRECIATE- MY COLLEAGUES
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS. AND
RICHARD WILL BE COMING BACK TO
THIS I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE
WHO- PARTICIPATED- TODAY
APPRECIATE ALL OF YOUR HARD WORK
THAT YOU DO THE SERVICE THAT YOU
PERFORM FOR CALIFORNIA AND- AND
HELP US TO BETTER UNDERSTAND-
ALL OF THESE POLICIES IN THE
FORM OF A BUDGET. BUDGETS ALWAYS
FOR A REFLECTION OF OUR VALUES
SO THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO ANYONE
WANTING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT REGARDING ANY OF THE
ISSUES THAT WE DISCUSSED TODAY
AS A REMINDER TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE
SIX FOUR. AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
THREE FIVE THREE ONE TWO EIGHT
THREE DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF HEARINGS
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS AND
CLEANING PROTOCOLS. WE WILL
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY TODAY I'M GOING TO ASK
THAT EACH MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
PROVIDING COMMON KEEP THEIR
REMARKS WELL WITHIN A MAXIMUM OF
ONE MINUTE. AND I'D LIKE TO ASK
ME- MODERATOR THE MODERATOR. OF
TO GET READY FOR THAT LET'S
BEGIN WITH ANY WITNESSES HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM SEEN NONE. COM
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT AND I WILL ASK-
CAN YOU GIVE US THE TOTAL NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFY.
THANK YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO TO. TESTIFY FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THIS TIME AND A T. T.
OPERATOR WILL QUICKLY GIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER OFFLINE IN THE NOT
PLACE YOU BACK INTO THE QUEUE
CAN FOR PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY EUROPE
THIS TIME. AT THE CURRENT MOMENT
WE HAVE THREE PARTICIPANTS CUED
UP MADAM CHAIR. OKAY MR-
MODERATE IF YOU WOULD OPEN THE
LINES CALL THEM AND- MOVE
FORWARD WITH- COLIN CLARK CALL
IN PARTICIPANTS. WHAT DO AND AS
A FINAL REMINDER I GO EIGHT
EIGHT ONE ZERO TO PUT YOURSELF
IN QUEUE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT AND
LYFT TWENTY THREE YOU ARE OPEN.
GOOD MORNING TURN MEMBERS DANIEL
SANCHEZ ON BEHALF OF THE CHEAP
PROBATION OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIA- JUST WANT TO SPEAK
BRIEFLY TO ISSUE SEVEN. ON
CALENDAR AND LIMITATION
PARTICULARLY- REFLECTING UPON
THE COMMENTS MADE. BY THIS
COMMITTEE THIS MORNING ON HOW
BEST WE CAN COLLECTIVELY ALIGN
EXISTING- PRE AND POST RELEASE
PROGRAMS- AND ONLINE NEEDS-
IMPORTANT SERVICES. AT THE STATE
LOOKS TO STREAMLINE SERVICES TO
THE JUSTICE INVOLVED POPULATIONS
THROUGH COLLEEN. WE WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THE IMPORTANCE OF
COLLABORATION WITH PROBATION TO
ENSURE THE INTERSECTION OF
RESOURCES ARE ALIGNED. AND NOT
DUPLICATED WITH THE SERVICES
PROVISION CURRENTLY PROVIDES-
AND THEY I THINK WE ALL SHARE
THE GOAL THAT KELLY PRESENTS AN
IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD
UPON THE WORK DONE BY PROBATION
AND FURTHER DEVELOP PROPERTIES.
THAT ENHANCE THE SERVICES FOR
INDIVIDUALS TRANSITIONING TO THE
COMMUNITY. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING OUR WORK WITH STATE
AGENCIES THIS COMMITTEE AND THE
LEGISLATURE IN IMPLEMENTING
TALLYING. TO SUPPORT JUSTICE
INVOLVED INDIVIDUALS AND FURTHER
ENHANCING THE IMPORTANT
CONTINUITYTHAT IS NEEDED AND
THEIR TRANSITION. THANK YOU. BUT
THANK YOU AND WE APPRECIATE ALL
THE WORK OF A OUR PROBATION
OFFICERS. ACROSS THE STATE NEXT
PLEASE. BY TWENTY FIVE GO AHEAD
. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TYLER IN THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF ALCOHOL AND DRUG
PROGRAM EXECUTIVE REPRESENTING
SOMETHING CUTE THAT'S WATER
PROVIDERS ACROSS THE STATE
INCLUDING THE MAJORITY OUT STOP
PROGRAM CONTRACTORS OPERATING
RETURNING HOME WHILE INITIATIVE
WE'RE SUPPORTIVE OF ISSUE NUMBER
EIGHT ON THE AGENDA ON THE
CONTINUATION AND EXPANSION OF
RETURNING HOME WHILE THIS
PROGRAM HAS BEEN CRITICAL IN
SUPPORTING INDIVIDUALS REALLY.
WE ARE ON PAROLE AND PROBATION-
DURING COMBAT NINETEEN SERVING
OVER THIRTEEN THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS STATEWIDE AND JULY
TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY MANY O WHOM
REQUIRE PRIOR TO THAT THE
MISSION IT DID NOT HAVE
IDENTIFIED HOUSING WE LOOK
FORWARD TO PRODUCTIVE
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE LEGISLATURE
ADMINISTRATION I'M THE CONTRARY
CONTINUATION OF RETURNING. HOME
WHILE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ONE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS CHRISTY I'M A
SURVIVOR HARM I'M A MEMBER OF
HURT CALIFORNIA'S UNITED BECAUSE
THEY'RE FOR RESPONSIBLE BUDGET
I'M ALSO CONSTITUENTS OF SENATOR
CORTESE. IF YOU WANT CONDUCT
MCCARTY WILL NOT BE CORRECTED BY
MANY THIRTY FIVE POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS ON NEW
MONITORING SYSTEM. THAT
MISCONDUCT ITSELF IS A DIRECT
RESULT OF SYSTEMIC HARM THAT
COMES FROM A CULTURE OF
PUNISHMENT AND THE UNDERMINING
OF HUMAN LIFE. SHOULD SHUT DOWN
AN EXISTING SHOULD BE REDIRECTED
INTO OTHER CAREERS THAT ARE
AIMED AT SUSTAINING COMMUNITY
RESOURCES THAT DO NOT INCLUDE
JANET CORRECT. CORRECTION TO
PARAPHRASE WHEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JUMPERS THAT YESTERDAY THE
FAMILY OF FIVE COMMITTEE MEETING
WE WANTED TO GET- I DO MORE
RESEARCH. THEY HAVE MORE
OVERSIGHT MONITOR ALL TYPES OF
CLAIMS AND THANK I'M LOOKING AT
AN ALPHABET SOUP. OF BUREAUCRACY
. ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA I'M
GONNA. WE LOST THEY- ARE AND
THEN BE HELD LONGER THING THANK
YOU ALL ALL OF YOUR WORK IT'S
VERY VERY DIFFICULT. ON THE
FAMILY. ONE THANK YOU FOR
CALLING NECK PLEASE. PINE TWENTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS LYDIA CAMPBELL I'M
CALLING IN AS A PRIVATE CITIZEN
TO EXPRESS CONCERNS REGARDING
ISSUE THREE EIGHTY A FUNDING THE
PROPOSAL FOR CHANGES TO PRISON
INFRASTRUCTURE DOES NOTHING TO
ADDRESS THE SYSTEMIC ABUSE
NEGLECT AND DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST INCARCERATED PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. NOR DOES IT
ADDRESS THE FACT THAT ACCEPT
EXCESSIVE SENTENCES AS WELL AS A
LACK OF PROPER HEALTH CARE
NUTRITION AND FITNESS ARE
DIRECTLY RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
NUMBER OF INCARCERATED PEOPLE
WHO EXPERIENCE DISABILITY NO
AMOUNT OF FUNDING OR
INFRASTRUCTURE MODIFICATIONS
WILL PREVENT CDC ARE FROM
COMMITTING THESE ATROCITIES THEY
MUST BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE AND ALL
PRISONS MUST BE SHUT DOWN. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
CALLING IN. A TO OUR NEXT PLEASE
MODERATOR. THANK YOU OUR LADY
ARE LEFT LYING TWENTY EIGHT YOU
ARE OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS KIMBERLY ALLEN FROM
ACCREDITED AGAIN CALIFORNIA LOS
ANGELES. CA NINE ZERO ZERO TWO
EIGHT. I WANT TO SPEAK ON ISSUES
SIX. NINE ACTUALLY ON YOU KNOW-
PEOPLE CAN'T GET WELL IN THIS
AND YOU KNOW THE INVEST IN
INCARCERATION PEOPLE WITH- DRUG
PROBLEMS IT'S NOT A GOOD
INVESTMENT WE NEED TO BE THE
STATE NEEDS TO BE INVESTING IN A
REASONABLE. AND DRUG TREATMENT
OUTSIDE OF THE PRISON AND NOT
WITHIN THE PRESIDENT SECOND- I
REALLY APPRECIATE- CENTER CORD
SHE BELIEVES ON REGARDS. TO JOBS
THAT ARE THIRTY CENTS AN HOUR-
NOT ONLY YOU KNOW PREVENT THOSE
PRISONERS BEING TO PAY. AND HAVE
MONEY ON PERCENT. FOR OR THEY
GET OUT OF PREPARING BUT THE
FACT THE ANSWER CANNOT BE A BAN
ON WHETHER THEY CAN GET JOB.
OUTSIDE OF PRISON AND BE HAVING
BETTER TRY AT LAW- IS REALLY. SO
I BELIEVE IN THE IN RENEWABLE
BUT INCREASE. AND POST RELEASE
VERSUS JIM MORE MORE IN IN
ACROSS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR CALLING. NEXT
PLEASE. TWENTY NINE YOUR OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
HIGHEST WOMANIZER AND I'M A
CONSTITUENT OF SENATOR WIENER'S
A MEMBER OF STORAGE AREA. I'M
CALLING ABOUT ISSUE FIVE AND
OTHERS ON YOUR AGENDA BECAUSE
THE CURRENT PREVALENCE OF
HEPATITIS C. IN CALIFORNIA
PRESENCE. I THINK OF MY FATHER.
I'M THE ADOPTED DAUGHTER OF A
FORMERLY INCARCERATED PERSONS.
SURVIVOR MY FATHER HAD INDOOR
THE CURRENT CONDITIONS I MIGHT
NOT OF HOW TO BOTHER AT ALL. K.
FOR THAT AND OTHER REGIONS IN
PRISONS ALL I CAN EVER SEE IS
PEOPLE WHO SHOULD RETURN TO
THEIR COMMUNITIES SO THEY CAN
BUILD. THEIR KIDS DANCE
PERFORMANCES YOUNG COACH KEELY
STOCKER WE BUILT A HOUSE IN THE
FAMILY. LIFE I BELIEVE IN
DIVESTMENT FROM ALL SYSTEMS OF
INCARCERATION AND RE INVESTMENT
IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNIVERSAL
HEALTHCARE JOB TRAINING PROGRAMS
AND OTHER ELEMENTS OF THIS CASE
AND HELP THE COMMUNITY. I ASK
YOU TO CLOSE ALL PRESENCE
STARTING WITH THE FACILITIES
IDENTIFIED BY KIRBY. I ENCOURAGE
THIS COMMITTEE TO- GOOD NIGHT
ALL PROPOSED. INCREASES CHIU CDC
ARE THANK YOU FOR LISTENING TO
THE COMMENTS. THANK YOU FOR
CALLING AND SHARING YOUR
PERSONAL STORY PREACHING TO NEXT
PLEASE. HELLO EVERYONE THERE. I
AM SORRY MY LINE WAS MUTED THEIR
LINE THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOU ARE OPEN. IN NINETEEN NINETY
IS ALYSSA GRANT AND MEMBER
SHOWING UP FOR RACIAL JUSTICE
THURSDAY. WHICH IS ON THE ORG.
UP CALIFORNIA UNITED PURPOSE
BUDGET A CURB SHE CAN BEGIN
TODAY ON ISSUE. I WANT TO URGE
THE COMMITTEE COULD NOT THAT IN
EIGHTY EIGHT CONSTRUCTION OR ANY
OTHER IMPRINTS REPAIRS OR- UNTIL
CDC HAPPY PLAN. ON WHICH PRISON
- I ACTUALLY CIRCLE. I SIMPLY
NOT BELIEVERS ABOUT GREAT. AND
IT MAY THE CAUSE. I HAVE THE TO
BE DE I AND THE PLAN CLOSURE IF
YOU SEE THE AND I. SUPPORT PLAN
TO QUIT EIGHT IT IS PRINTER IN
THE NEXT FIVE YEARS. AND FOR NOT
ALLAH BY FOR AND INTEREST OR
PROJECT UNTIL A CLEAR FOR PRISON
BECAUSE INCLUDING. PRESIDENT
BECAUSE IT'S PRESENTED TODAY
COMMITTEE. I'M A LOT MADE AFTER
REVIEWING THE AGENDA I LOOK BACK
ON SEVEN DVR IS NOT PLAN FOR
INCREASED. AND NO THAT ON THE
TWO NINETEEN AFTER INCLUDED OVER
MILLION DOLLAR OF. FOR IN.
PROJECT I. WHICH IS GOING TO AT
BEEN QUITE. THAT AND YOUR REACH
MALE DOLLARS MY EACH PROJECT
RECOUP. I'LL THOUGHT THAT FROM
SEVEN TO TWENTY IRA YOUR EMAIL
DOLLARS IN REPAIRS AND NOW IT'S
QUITE. I DON'T TIME THE TEAM
WOULD HAVE THE LIGHT MILLION
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
REPAIRS AND A NEW THAT HE I
WOULD HER CLOSER SEE THERE ARE.
I'M NOT SURE HOW YOU CAN MAKE
WITH TO. ABOUT SPENDING WITHOUT
A CLEAR PLAN FOR PERSONAL
PLEASURE AND I URGE YOU CAN DENY
INTO PER. HELLO A REAL PRISON
BECAUSE WITH CLEAR TIME MY AND
PRESENT TO BE CITY CARD IS THAT
. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
APPRECIATED IN. MODERATOR PLEASE. MYERS TREATMENT FUNDING-
BECAUSE I AM CONCERNED ABOUT THE
FACT THAT MORE THAN 60% OF THE
INCARCERATED POPULATION AND GDP
. IMPROPER CONDUCT HEPATITIS C.
INFECTION AND ACTUALLY PUT THEIR
FLEETING BECAUSE OF BAD IN
CALIFORNIA PROGRAM. OR IS THE
TRUTH PRINT THEM ARE ON HOW AND
- BASICALLY WHO BUT WE BETTER
LONG TERM PRODUCT COULD BE. YEAH
ANOTHER WAY. THAT RATED AND
INCOME. IN THE PALM HEALTH. YEAH
OF COURSE PEOPLE FROM HEPATITIS
DECLARED PROPER. REPENT BUT THAT
TREATMENT DOESN'T HAVE TO HAPPEN
IN PRISON AND H. BE ABOUT. I'M
CALLING TO GET BY THE COURT CRUZ
CALLED RENEW THE ELDERLY AND
MEDIC WALDRON INCOME. TO ALL.
CLOSED AND TO READ SAVINGS FROM
BECAUSE INTO CALLED TO KEEP US
ALL SAFE INCLUDING AND THIS
CREATING FOR THE CURRENTLY
COOPER COULD HAVE A TENDENCY.
AND PSYCHIATRIC PHARMACY
PROVIDER HERE I WANT TO COMMENT
ON SPECIFIC ON ISSUE SIX- WELL
YOU KNOW- MAINTAINS THAT WHILE
THIS IS BEST SERVED IN THE
COMMUNITY PEOPLE CANNOT GET WELL
FROM SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS IN
IN THE CARCERAL SETTING. THE
GUIDANCE IS CLEAR ROUGHLY 40% OF
PEOPLE IN JAILS AND PRISONS FROM
MY COUNTY ARE HAVE A MENTAL
HEALTH PROBLEM AND THE EVIDENCE
IS QUITE CLEAR THAT THERE'S
NOTHING THAT'S GOING TO GET
BETTER WITH CDC ARE SCALED AND-
IRRESPONSIBLE. APPROACH TO
REHABILITATION MORE PEOPLE
SHOULD BE RELEASED PRISON SHOULD
BE CLOSED IN THE STATE BUDGET
SHOULD SHIFT SUPPORT AND FUNDING
TO COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THAT PROVIDE NECESSARY WELLNESS
SERVICES. INCLUDING SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER TREATMENT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR.
MODERATOR OUR NEXT PARTICIPANT.
AND WE WILL LINE THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU- MY
NAME IS MEGAN SCHWARTZ AND I'M
CALLING FROM ALAMEDA COUNTY I'M
A MEMBER OF THE CHURCH AREA AND
CURB AND I'M CALLING TODAY ON
AGENDA ITEM NUMBER THREE EIGHTY
EIGHT INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS.
WHICH WE KNOW ARE NECESSARY
BECAUSE OUR PRISON POPULATION IS
AGING. AND THE NUMBER OF-
INCARCERATED OLDER ADULTS IN
CALIFORNIA IS REALLY QUITE
STAGGERING- THIS IS A FINAL
KNOWN OUTSIDE OF THE U. S. OR TO
A LARGE PART DUE. TO- LONG LONG
SENTENCES THAT HAVE. RAN ENTIRE
- ARMED COMMUNITY- NEW ONE IN
FOUR PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA PRISON
PRISONS- IS AGE FIFTY OR OLDER-
THAT 24% OF THE TOTAL PRISON
POPULATION. THE SOLUTION TO THE
PROBLEM INSTEAD OF FOCUSING FUND
ON HOUSING- MORE ELDERLY
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS WEREN'T WE
TRYING TO GET THOSE FOLKS OUT OF
PRISON WHERE WE SHINING MORE
PRINT MOVES DOWN. AND CARING FOR
OUR ELDERS IN THE COMMUNITY AND
- JUST A REALLY DISTURBING
SITUATION THAT WE HAVE SO MANY
ELDER CALIFORNIANS IN OUR
PRESENCE AND- FURTHERMORE MORE
LOOKING AT GIVING MORE MONEY TO
CDC ARE WHEN THEY'VE- THE HEALTH
PROBLEMS IN THIS POPULATION
THEY- MADE PEOPLE- WHO AREN'T
THAT OLD- MUCH. OLDER THAN THEIR
CHRONOLOGICAL AGE WOULD TELL US
SO PLEASE- REJECTED FUNDS FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS AND
INSTEAD. PUT THOSE FUNDS INTO
OUR COMMUNITY AND SHUT DOWN 1%
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR CALLING
PRE SHOULD DO NEXT MODERATOR AND
COULD YOU TELL US HOW MANY.
CARDS THE COLORS ARE IN THE
QUEUE. RIGHT NOW- WE HAVE THREE
REMAINING. WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO
REPOPULATE MORE TIME. NO THAT'S
OKAY TO GO ON WITH THE THREE
REMAINING. THANK YOU ONE THIRTY
SIX YOU ARE OPEN. AND SENATORS
HI MY NAME IS DARBY KERN AND I
AM CALLING ON BEHALF OF AMITY
FOUNDATION AND THE WEST CARE
WE'RE BOTH PROVIDERS TO WORK
WITH EDT ARE HONORING ENTRY
PROGRAM AND COUNTIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. AND I WANT TO
COMMENT ON- AN ISSUE SEVEN AND
EIGHT I'M ISSUE SEVEN THE CALLIN
JUSTICE INVOLVED INITIATIVE THIS
IS A REALLY AMAZING OPPORTUNITY
FOR CALIFORNIA AND AS THEIR- AND
- INTO A- FULL PROGRAM I THINK
THE ONE THING WE REALLY WANT TO
MAKE SURE. IS THAT AND BUT THE
FUNDING THAT CDC ARE USES FOR IT
STOP IN RE ENTRY PROGRAMS TODAY-
IS STILL REMAIN AS- AN
OPPORTUNITY AS WE CHANGE OVER
THE SYSTEM BECAUSE ONE THING WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE IS THAT AS
COLLEEN INCIDENTAL MANAGED THAT
WE DON'T SEE. GEOGRAPHIC DROP IN
PROGRAM BECAUSE OF WHERE PEOPLE. ARE AND BEING RETURNED- ISSUE
EIGHT RETURNING HOME WELL- DID
IS BEEN A INCREDIBLE PRO. AND I
THINK THE ONLY CAN SHOWING TO
RAISE THAT THAT IT DIDN'T REALLY
BEING CAUGHT ABOUT HOW PROGRAM
AND THE REASON IT WAS THOSE. IN
SUCH A SHORT AMOUNT TIME THE
TREE YEAR THE BECAUSE IT WAS
TREATMENT. AND THE CORE SERVICE
. AND THE WANT TO MAKE YOUR THAT
HOUSING IS NOT THE SOLUTION- AND
FOR A LONG TERM ACTIVISM.
PRODUCTION WE NEED TO HAVE ALL
OF THE SERVICE WRAPPED AROUND
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE
PRECIADO THE- NEXT MODERATOR.
FIVE THIRTY FOR YOUR OPEN. MY
NAME IS DEBBIE FALAHEE I LIVE IN
ORANGE COUNTY WE HAVE MORE
PEOPLE IN PRISON THAN ANY OTHER
COUNTRY AND IT IS SHAMEFUL
INCARCERATION IS NOT GOING TO
MATTER CRISIS MY BROTHER SUFFERS
FROM MENTAL ILLNESS SOMETIMES
YEARS AND REASONABLE I'M SURE HE
WOULD NOT LAST SIX MONTHS IN
JAIL. I FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT WE
MUST DIVEST FROM SYSTEMS THAT
INCARCERATIONS AND INVEST IN
MAKING IT A SERVICE THAT WE ALL
KNOW TRULY KEEP ESTATE PUTTING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING MENTAL HEALTH
CARE JOB TRAINING AND MORE YEAH
THANK YOU FAILING INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENT IF THE PERMANENT
RECORD THEM NOT TOO LATE MORE
MONEY REPAIRING THEM AND EXPAND
THEM. WE NEED TO CONTINUE
CLOSING NOW- COMMITTEE TO
RECOMMEND ADDITIONAL PRO IN THE
NAME OF HEALTH PUBLIC STATE AND
RESPONSE. ABOUT HE DID THREE HA
OF OUR VALUES AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO HONESTLY. CAN SURE THAT WE
CAN BUT THE BUDGET REQUIRE THE
BASS MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIANS
RACIAL JUSTICE. ECONOMIC JUSTICE
. METAL JEFF AND PUBLIC HEALTH
HI. I CLOSING PRISONERS AND
INVESTING IN THAT NOT COMMUNITY
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME THANK YOU FOR CALLING. AUTO
NEXT. A LINE EIGHT PLEASE GO. A
GOOD MORNING THIS IS M. J. KING
AND I LIVE IN LOS ANGELES.
INCLUSION IMPORTANT TO ME IN
ORDER TO PROMOTE RACIAL EQUITY
AND MORE HEALTHY AND SUCCESSFUL
COMMUNITIES. ARE PHYSICALLY AND
ENVIRONMENTALLY TOXIC TO THE
COMMUNITY TO LOOK AROUND THEM.
TO THOSE WHO WORK INSIDE A
PRISON AND THOSE WHO ARE
INCARCERATED INSIDE. OUR MONEY
WOULD BE BETTER SPENT INVESTING
IN FUNDING ARE UNDER RESEARCH
COMMUNITIES TO PROMOTE EQUITY
ACROSS THE STATE. SRI INVESTING
IN OUR COMMUNITY OVER PUNISHMENT
ISN'T RADICAL SOCIAL SCIENTISTS
AND PUBLIC HEALTH EXPERTS HAVE
PROVEN THE INVESTMENT COMMUNITY
DECREASES CRIME AND THE NEED FOR
PUNISHMENT. IF WE DIDN'T SPEND
EIGHTEEN POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS AND PUNISHMENT EACH YEAR
WE COULD BETTER FIND COMMUNITY
RESOURCES TO PREVENT THE PROGRAM
PIPELINE FROM UNDER RESOURCED
COMMUNITIES. AND CREATE
HEALTHIER COMMUNITIES AND JOBS
FOR THOSE WHO LIVE AND WORK IN
PRINTOUT. I'M DISAPPOINTED TO
LEARN THAT GOVERNOR YUSUF BUDGET
DOUBLES DOWN ON COMMERCIAL
SPENDING. INCLUDING NO
ADDITIONAL PRISONS OF THEIR
CULTURE AND THE PROPOSED BUDGET
DESPITE THE FACT THAT A WHITE.
SPREAD RECOGNITION THAT PRISONS
ARE RACIST FISCALLY WASTEFUL AND
PUBLICLY MENTAL HEALTH DOCTORS.
THE INCREASE TO CBC BUDGET TO
FOURTEEN TWO BILL. DESPITE
HISTORICAL IN OUR STATE PRISON
POP. THE FIVE YEAR SEVEN HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY SIX HAVE NO DOLLARS
INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN. AND THAT
THE THREE HUNDRED NINE DOLLARS
R. J. DOLLARS FOR LONG. SPENDING
TO DOWN ON A PRO RETAIL CRIME
RIGHT. I ASKED IS CAN INITIAL
BOLD. I DO NOT CDCR INDUSTRY
INSTEAD. ONLY BEGINNING MONEY
AWAY FROM FEES ARE INTO LIKE A
FOR ANSWER. WILL BE BILLED UP
WHAT WE TRULY KEEPS OUR
COMMUNITIES. THANKS FOR YOUR
TIME THANK YOU CALLING MODERATOR
. ONE MORE. MATTER CHAIR WHICH I
ENERGY. ONE MORE PLAY THANK YOU
I WILL AND- THANK YOU. OKAY OUR
FINAL BUT COMMENTED WILL COME
FOR WIND FOR TO PLAY GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS SCOTT AND I CALLING A
SALON AS A OF OAK CAL. BY I
DIDN'T ON THE- OVER LAST YEARS
THE HELP WORKER GRANDPARENT
COMMUNITY. OF ALL SEEN AND HARM
COME PEOPLE AND COMMUNITY FROM
THE PRESS OF. THERE ARE PUBLIC
HEALTH. SO MANY. I SAW OPPOSE
ANY FUND TO SEE. INTEREST
PROJECTS AND COULD EIGHTY A WORK
. YOU SHOULDN'T BE IN. ELDER
DISABLED AND MEDICALLY. PEOPLE
IN THE FIRST PLACE. I SUPPORT
KURDS CALL IT A REALLY OF ALL
MY- FONG. AND ELDERLY CURSORY
INDIVIDUALS. TO PAVE THE WAY FOR
INCREASED PRISON CLOSER. TO A
BUDGET THAT REFLECTS
CALIFORNIANS DESIRE FOR RACIAL
ECONOMIC AND ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE AND PUBLIC HEALTH BY
CLOSING PRISONS THAN INVESTING
INSTEAD IN OUR COMMUNITY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I THANK
YOU MODERATOR APPRECIATE YOUR
SERVICE THIS MORNING. AND SINCE
WE'VE HEARD FROM THE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC. COLLEAGUES ANY LAST
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. C. NINE
THANK YOU DOCTOR BACK BILL THANK
YOU TO OUR STAFF AND EVERYONE
WHO'S MADE THIS A SUCCESSFUL
HEARING- THANK YOU EVERYONE IN
THE PUBLIC FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION ALL THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO PARTICIPATED IN OUR PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU WERE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE PUBLIC AND THE
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE.
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS THANK
YOU AGAIN AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION THE SENATE BUT IN
PHYSICAL REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE
FIVE IS NOW ADJOURNED.